So I've never been to woodland hills.
It's a rare land.
The land of would it smells like money?
Does it out here really?
It smells like like white people where
white people come to breed.
Hank shot.
Ladies and gentlemen,
we're live D.
Hank Shaw said woodland hills smells
like money.
You've got to go to Beverly Hills.
It smells like diamond.
They don't let people like me and they
don't know.
Come on man.
You look respectable.
Barely.
Are you looking fine?
You're a chef.
How do you go from being a political
blogger?
You are political blogger.
That was a political capital bureau
chief in Sacramento in another places in
covered congress.
So a bit more than a blogger.
But you are deep in.
Oh yeah.
I always in the room several times
watching this thing go down now this
atrocity of justice and voting and chaos
and all,
everything that's going around,
the Russians are attacking all this
stuff that's going on right now.
What?
What does this feel like to you?
It feels so good to not be doing this
job anymore.
I just,
I feel like anybody that has any sort of
intelligence that is a political blogger
that's involved in it for any length of
time or not as political blogger and
columnist and author.
After awhile you got to realize you're,
you're fucking writing about pro
wrestling.
This is a rig system.
You're writing about a rigged system and
then occasionally something like this
happens.
It used to be,
I mean,
what got me into,
I did for 18 years,
wow.
I got into it because when I got into
it,
the essence of politics with people of
different kinds of backgrounds and
persuasions or different regions would
all meet in a room.
I either capital either as a state
capitol Congress and solve a problem
somehow.
So it was all about compromise and
debate and wheeling and dealing and that
kind of stuff.
Which is inherently fascinating when
you're a report like whose ox is going
to get cord?
Who's going to win this?
And like,
you know,
joe needs this and somebody else needs
that.
I got to give him this thing.
Otherwise I'm not going to do is vote
and Dah,
Dah,
Dah.
And then the,
at the end of the day,
you'd have this bill,
this transportation,
I mean,
I could go on about some hilarious
congressional stories and in state
government stories do.
So there was a transportation bill
[inaudible] bill in Congress in 98.
And one of my guys,
a guy named Frank Wolf,
he was a,
is a lawmaker from northern Virginia.
He's not there anymore.
He used kind of a do gooder,
you know,
kind of a reformer Republican guy,
Dudley direct kind of guy and he wanted,
he hated pork and want to get rid of all
the earmarks in transportation bill.
But as you probably know,
the transportation bill is what they
call a Christmas tree.
So everybody gets a little bit of an
ornament on top of the tree so that they
can go home to their district and say,
look what I got.
So Bud,
Schuster of Pennsylvania with the head
of the transportation committee back
then.
So Bud,
uh,
would shut the door and anybody in the
transportation committee with one of
Bud's boys,
you are a Republican,
you want a Democrat,
you one of Bud's boys.
And so they all play a game like this
and so except for my guy,
my guy would come out and hold press
releases saying,
oh,
are,
you know,
it was a terrible,
this is,
this is corruption,
blah,
blah blah.
Now the game is played,
you know,
everybody gets it.
Everybody gets a little piece.
So it comes out and the bill passes over
frank's dead body basically,
and he holds a press release or a press
conference talking about how terrible it
all was.
And I'm coming out of this press
conference and one of Bud Schuster's
aids comes and says,
hey,
check out page.
I can't remember.
It was a page 123 of the bill.
So I did.
And in there was a line item that gave
the residents of Bud Schuster's
congressional district a free pass to
drive the Pennsylvania turnpike for x
number of years.
So basically anybody who lived in Bud's
district didn't have to pay tolls for,
I think it was two years.
Awesome.
That's ridiculous.
Well,
there was a reason because,
uh,
the,
the road that most of those people took
to work was being,
there was going be construction on it
for like the next two years.
Oh,
well that's fairly reasonable.
Then you could justify it in front of a
court of law is not completely,
but you know,
I mean cases where like,
yeah,
check out into page 423.
We stuck something in there that's still
going on too.
I mean that,
that's what's so bizarre that even in
this age of transparency,
there's still like stacking stuff in
sliding things into bills and there's
very few people to watch them now.
Yes.
And there's too many things to look at
anyway,
even if there is something.
Yeah,
something does get in,
there's gonna be some new scandal
tomorrow.
Kanye west going to be visiting trump at
the trump tower and that like,
you're not going to think about the bill
anymore.
Exactly.
There's too much to pay attention to
Hank Shaw,
which is why I find it fascinating that
you went from that world too,
like much more of an artistic pursuit of
being a chef.
And that's something that I've really
come to appreciate over the last,
say 10 years or so.
And I credit the initial push to,
uh,
watching,
no reservations when Anthony Bourdain
show was on the travel channel.
Um,
because I,
I always loved food,
you know,
I,
I like eating.
Everybody does,
you know,
but I never really thought of dieticians
don't like eating.
Which,
which ones are your dieticians?
They don't,
they don't like it.
Well,
they don't like the pleasure aspect of
it.
They want everybody to just say like,
if there's a fucking guy that I know,
there's like a,
I don't eat for taste.
I eat for performance.
He eats like a oatmeal with water and he
doesn't heat it up.
I'm like,
get the fuck Outta here.
You asshole.
Just,
you're missing the point.
You could do both stupid.
But um,
the point being that I didn't think I
thought of food as being like great.
Like,
oh,
this is good,
I like this.
I didn't think of it as an art and then
when I watched Anthony Bourdain show,
when he would have these great reverence
for these people that he would visit,
who are these real artists and they were
put together these amazing dishes and
the enthusiasm and the passion that he
had for describing it made me super
excited about it.
And then I started realizing,
Oh wow,
I never thought about it like this.
This is an art form.
This is just an art form.
Like you know,
in a way that you would like to make a
sand castle know it's not going to last
forever.
You're making a meal.
You can take a photo of it.
It is not unlike standup comedy in a lot
of it's performance art.
Yeah.
The last.
For as long as you're in the restaurant
or as long as you're in that comedy
hall.
Yeah.
If,
if like,
you couldn't record comedy where you
could record
a meal and film it.
Like on Anthony Bourdain shot.
I can't appreciate it at home,
but I could watch you if you did stand
up and I laughed at home.
I don't have to be there.
That's true.
It,
it,
it serves more people,
but in the sense the same way.
Like,
like if there was no
recordings,
it would be kind of very similar and a
lot of ways but shared for with larger
groups of people.
Right.
I enjoyed cooking.
When you bring it up to that kind of a
level,
and I still,
I,
I hesitate to use the word artists with,
with cooks and she sounds pretentious.
Right?
Were were artisans.
We're craftsman.
Were artists too.
Like what's the difference?
Well,
okay,
so there are some people who will say
that my cooking leaves you with a deep
feeling of whatever you know,
on Wifi or happiness or joy or parts or
whatever.
And,
and like,
no,
we're cooking good food.
We are buying product,
we're making product and in a way that
will make you interested in it and will
delight you in some way,
shape or form.
And you know,
there's a famous old,
a Spanish chef whose name escapes me at
the end of every Michelin Star meal ends
with the good shit
looking it.
I just don't want to take myself that
seriously.
Well,
good for you.
But that's the same thing as comedians.
Like my comedy changes worlds,
changes minds.
It influence.
I mean,
the influencer is,
it's,
I think it's important to get my message
out there and use my platform.
No,
dude,
you're joking.
You're telling.
You're making people laugh.
I ultimately.
Well,
what comics are freed from that today?
Uh,
in this very unique form because of the
Internet and because of the podcast.
So because of podcasts,
comics,
if you have,
if you have actually something that you
want to say that is not necessarily
funny,
you could do that now because podcasts
are so open ended.
There's no real structure to it.
Whereas like if you go on stage and
people did for the longest time,
they would go on stage and rant about
the government or about abortion or
about crime or whatever and it would be
not funny and they would feel like it
was.
It was something that was important.
So it had to be discussed even though it
was discussed in this weird forum where
people go to pay to see comedy and
you're not giving them comedy.
You're ranting.
And it was almost like respected under
like some snobbish sort of sect of
standup comedy fans and practitioners.
There's a real weird was I blame Bill
Hicks,
you know Bill Hicks's?
Yeah.
Bill Hicks did it perfectly,
but the way he did it,
he fuck every lot of people imitated it
to the point where there's a famous,
a comedy club in Georgia called the
punchline that went under and it had a
back room that the green room where the
comics would hang out and they'll.
Everybody wrote on the walls and a one
section of this wood paneled wall said,
quit trying to be Hicks.
And uh,
Jamie,
the owner says it's going to get me that
because they tore it down.
They saved that.
Those pieces.
Put it up in here.
Someone by by all means make a statement
but make it funny.
Yeah,
man,
that's where it's hard.
It's hard to do that.
But.
So some people like took the shortcut
and they just want it to be self
righteous.
It's hard to do molecular gastronomy and
make it actually soulful molecular
gastronomy is when he's calling cooking
ladies and gentlemen.
Not now my cooking,
but tweezers,
foams,
verification,
calcium,
lactate,
all that kind of.
What is that all about?
Like some people go too deep,
right?
Yeah.
Well you kind of the opposite.
You're like,
one of the things that I've really
enjoyed about seeing some of your dishes
that you like to cook.
Things like say if you're cooking like a
wild pork Loin,
you want to use a lot of the ingredients
that are in the area where that animal
lives.
Yeah.
I'm not the first person to do that,
but it's one of the things that I do a
lot of what goes together in the field
or in the water and the seashore or
whatever,
almost always will go together and on
the plate.
So I mean,
I've gotten to.
It's weird stuff is,
you know,
when I go grouse hunting,
well,
what were the graphs eating?
You can tell what was in the product and
like,
I'll never forget there was this moment
in um,
we are in North Dakota hunting sharp
tailed grouse and the graphs had all
been eating rose hips.
So I'm like,
I've got gotta make a rose hip glaze on
these sharpies of rose hip Glenn.
What does rose hips taste like?
Um,
they're a little bit like a,
well,
they're loaded with vitamin C so they
have that kind of acidy toying to them,
but
there
like imagine a cross between a
watermelon and an orange or something
like that.
That's what rose hips tastes like.
Why don't we just buy rose hips to the
store and eat them?
Uh,
because the center of a rose hip is what
they used to make itching powder out of.
That's what it looks like,
Jamie.
I'm looking at.
That's,
that's a rose hip.
It's a fruit.
It,
it's,
it's the end of the rose.
And I mean that's what a bit rose
becomes really.
There's a variety called A.
Yeah.
How the fuck do I not know this?
I have roses.
Well,
they don't all,
they don't always get pollinated.
Oh.
So when they get pollinated,
the best one is called a regresa rose.
And it is a,
it's a coastal reslizumab beaches and
dunes and the roasted there.
It's like the size of a cherry pepper.
It's like that.
Wow.
Yeah.
That's something that's solid,
you know,
half dollar size.
People remember what half dollar looks
like.
It's that big and it's juicy,
like a,
like a sweet pepper,
but you don't eat the center because the
center is what they used to make itching
powder out of
itching powder.
Oh Jesus Christ.
So it's like one of those kind of eat
around the edge,
low fish that can kill you,
like kind of a deal.
But it just,
it's not that bad.
No.
But the outside's Yummy.
Yeah.
Wow.
Fucking how bizarre.
Put that photo up again.
I literally had no idea that they looked
like that center part is nasty.
Nasty.
Now if it dries in you,
um,
so what?
I make a roasted puree.
So get these,
that kind of rose hip and dry it and um,
and then you rehydrate it and then you
boil it just to get it soft and then you
run it through a food mill.
And so only the red flesh comes through
and all those seeds stay in the food
mill and you get this incredibly amazing
looking paste that looks exactly like
tomato paste,
but it's like concentrated roset flavor.
Oh.
And it's ridiculously good.
Wow.
And that's what is that back there to
back that up one,
Jeremy?
That's like a puree or something.
Is that like how they would make that?
W would grind that up in some sort of a
way?
It's probably,
yeah,
it's probably the extract.
I mean,
they make jellies out of it a lot and
um,
the,
the Swedes and Norwegians make um,
fruit soup out of it.
How do I not know this,
this,
this.
So I really thought rose hips were
somehow or another,
like a rose leaf.
I thought you'd take like the.
Because I know those things must taste
good because deer eat them like crazy.
Oh yeah.
They,
they like.
My friend's wife was like,
oh,
I love animals.
It's so cute.
We have deers in the same way.
They started planning the roses,
the deer Cape beat the rose and she's
like,
these fucking cuts need to die.
Kill them,
kill them off.
So his.
I saw his wife literally wants to murder
these deer because they're killing her
flowers.
It's fun.
It's like 100.
We need a tag.
Yeah.
Going to try to get a tag for Malibu,
Malibu.
Lots of luck.
I know.
Malibu.
Just granted a stay.
A pardon on that mountain lion who's
been killing all the alpacas up there.
And I heard that story.
No,
but it's awesome.
It's a fascinating story because there
is a mountain,
mine's name is p 45.
He's actually been collared and they
know who he is,
they know he's an active Radio Colorado,
so they know it's him and he's just
murking these alpacas.
He killed was 11 alpacas and stupidest
slow as dear I've ever.
Chest cage.
He does opposite fence.
It has a slaughter fest.
I mean,
he's not even eating them.
He's just fucking them up,
you know,
I think he's plenty of food up there.
He's just decided to eat them because
they were killed them because they were
there.
And so they decided that they could pay,
they could,
uh,
pass a,
um,
depredation permit so they're going to
kill him.
And so then in this outrage and the
woman who owns the Alpaca farm account,
apparently it was like really scared
because she was like,
I just wasn't prepared for the vitriol.
And so now she doesn't want it killed.
She's not going to use the depredation
order.
She's instead wants someone to somehow
or another take it away and put it
somewhere else.
Probably up in nor cal where I live.
I've seen five mountain lions wandering
around in the wild.
I mean we throw around.
Oh,
there's a lot.
There's one today.
They kitties.
There's once a day,
a video they put up of this guy in his
home,
looks out on his front porch and there's
a fucking mountain lion killing a deer
on his front porch.
It was just put out today.
Did you see a jamie?
You see that one is crazy.
I mean it's.
It's in a suburban neighborhood is a big
cat too and it's just dragging this deer
on his,
on his front porch.
Like,
whoa.
Jesus Christ.
Here it is.
Like this is this guy security.
The mountain lion was caught on camera
Thursday attacking a deer to residents.
Front porch in Sanford,
San Francisco.
Yes.
Watch.
Look at this and this is fucking San
Francisco.
San Francisco is dragging the deer way.
This is crazy.
That's amazing.
Because both of us have been to San
Francisco.
That thing must be living in golden gate
park.
Well,
the crazy part came up from the
peninsula where there's a fair bit of
habitat for it.
It's very strange what they're able to
do and how they're able to move around.
They're just so smart of the deer had
been eaten.
Rosa say fuck them sometimes you got to
pay rent amount.
Mountain Lion inspired by the fucking
rose owners.
The Jack.
The deer.
Yeah.
It's up there.
It's amazing how they can get around.
They killed a giant one in Santa Monica
in someone's backyard.
Santa Monica was just like deeply
populated and uh,
this,
this guy called up the police I guess
and said,
hey,
there's a fucking giant mountain lion in
my yard.
And they couldn't figure it out.
How to get it out of there.
This,
they killed it.
It was,
you know,
150 pound cat in Santa Monica just
wandering.
Pretty big.
They get bigger.
Do they be really 100?
Do they get to go?
Yeah.
That's a giant big kitty.
You see them in like Utah.
Well,
I was listening to this podcast
yesterday where this,
uh,
they were talking about spotting Jaguars
in Arizona.
They're spotting and more and more
lately,
especially the spotted a couple of them
now and in the south.
And that to in Texas to really very
southern part of Texas.
It's so interesting.
It's so.
It's like part of you is like,
yeah,
that's cool.
They're coming back.
You're part of them was like,
it's cool.
As long as there's only a couple of
them.
Right.
You don't want too many jaguars were
running around where the kids are
playing.
It's like sea lions.
I have nothing against the lions,
but there aren't enough great white
sharks to make the sea lion population
kind of normal.
So we're just blitzed with sea lions up
in northern California.
Have you ever seen the video that they
took of people?
Right on fisherman's wharf?
He took his Mahi Mahi.
It's.
No,
no,
no.
The,
the,
the.
They're killing seals or sea lions.
They're killing seals and fisherman's
wharf,
giant,
huge sharks.
Sharks.
Murking these sea lions right next to
the fisherman's wharf.
So these people were there filming and
then see that while they're hanging out
here is right.
Yeah,
exactly.
Yeah.
These people are hanging out and like,
yeah,
yeah.
Well,
you know,
we're just going to.
Oh Shit,
boom.
I look at all the blood in the water,
I mean,
then they all come to the,
to the side of the edge to look over
over the edge of the dock.
And I guess this is a security camera
that's on this boat.
It's filming this,
but if you look at all the fucking
blood,
yeah,
this
one's rapidly cooling.
Um,
I've caught all kinds of sharks.
You see where the,
uh,
that power boat is in the background.
Go about 150 yards towards Alcatraz or
you know,
or actually as towards Angel Island.
Um,
and uh,
and there are seven guild sharks,
big,
big seven guild sharks that live in that
channel.
What's under d?
Seven guild sharks at different type of
shark.
It is,
it's a really,
really primitive kind of shark.
They're actually quite tasty.
Um,
and you're allowed one a day and they
cruise the bottom and the deep channels
in San Francisco Bay,
that's actually one of the best places
to catch them outside of New Zealand.
Um,
how deep is.
That can be over a hundred.
So you just trolled the bottom or you
just draw a line down a either anchor up
or you already bounced bottom.
Oh Wow.
What a cool looking shark.
Yeah,
the crazy looking.
Wow.
They do look really primitive.
You know,
it's interesting.
Sharks because of the whole shark fin
soup controversy.
This,
which is not good by the way,
if you've ever had it.
I have had it once and I'm like,
no,
thank you.
It was okay.
I mean,
it wasn't anything that I think you
should slaughter sharks.
Precisely.
Especially not just the fin,
like it's so bizarre.
Worse.
There's so much meat on a shark.
The single worst,
you know,
but what I was going to say is that
there's this new sort of liberal knee
jerk reaction to sharks that now you're
not supposed to kill sharks.
So there was a,
I think it was the mayor of New York
City,
or was it the governor that caught a
thresher shark and it's not an
endangered species.
It's a totally legal fish to catch.
And you'll see him at fish markets and
he caught it and cooked it and people
just jumped on the outrage train and
started getting angry that he was
killing endangered sharks.
And there was like,
well blah,
blah,
blah.
This is not.
We're not making shark fin soup.
We're not some gigantic Chinese
commercial fishing vehicle right.
Here it is.
New York governor in hot water over
sharp photo.
And that's a little fresher to.
It's totally legal.
Yeah.
So it's a fish.
I mean,
it's not a fish,
it's a shark,
but it's,
uh,
it's,
it's no different.
I mean,
it's what I mean,
I get that a lot because,
um,
I fish for leopard sharks in San
Francisco Bay and Tamales Bay,
they're delicious.
They're fantastic.
And everyone gets.
I get the same reaction,
but I'm like,
wait,
wait.
First of all,
they're a species of least concern if
you look at all the fish monitoring
things or whatever.
And we're keeping like for,
for the whole season.
And because they can get reasonably big
and they're there,
it's just,
it's the,
it's the common shark that lives up
there.
And everybody,
I think that when you get down to it as
Americans are not very good at nuance,
right.
And you know,
it's like,
oh well one sharks endangered so they
all must be endangered.
I was like,
no.
Well there's a very cursory glimpse at
the facts and what it,
what they're going to get outraged at
before they decide to pull the outrage
shoot.
They're just like,
pull it,
pull it.
He's got a shark.
It eop outrage.
They just,
they don't,
I,
I mean there's not enough time in the
day to really pay attention to all the
different animals that are being
consumed and how you,
what you should be concerned with and
whatnot.
So you think,
I think I read somewhere that sharks are
endangered and he's got a sharp hey man,
fuck you.
And they just say filet of fish.
And there's namec eating fries,
cooked in beef fat as there were on the
way over there.
Which are good by the way.
Yeah,
they're great.
But these leopard sharks now,
what is the difference in like,
I've had Makos the only shark I've ever
eaten.
What would you say a leopard would be?
Dramatically different because makers
and treasures are much more like
swordfish.
So if I were swordfish,
sturgeon makers and threshers all kind
of on the same culinary bucket,
they're like a steak,
like a thick mia.
I liked that.
A lot of people don't though,
right?
Some people don't know,
you know,
no accounting for taste,
but a leopard sharks.
But you have down here in cal,
um,
leopard shark is super,
super white.
Uh,
it's very dense.
Um,
it's a little bit more like grouper is
interesting.
It's an amazing now.
I mean,
there's a trick to it.
So if you're going to fit for these
fish,
you need to have ice on board,
um,
and you need to basically catch the
fish.
You kill the fish.
Um,
and then you got the fish right there
and then you'd get them on ice because
Sharks Skates and rays effectively pee
through their skin.
So.
So if you don't get the fish right after
you kill it,
you get this buildup of uric acid in the
meat.
And it's basically your fish filets
going to smell like ammonia,
which nobody likes.
So that's,
that's interesting.
Skates and rays are the same as well.
So all three,
I think if I remember,
they're a less.
I'm going to forget.
It's a plasma allows momorphism I forgot
what the scientific name is,
but it's the cartilaginous fish now.
The variations and sharks.
That's a very extreme variation.
The difference between like a grouper
and a swordfish,
which is like a real thick midi wha.
What,
what accounts for that diet?
Diet.
Yeah.
Um,
leopard sharks,
like the crabs,
crustaceans,
a shellfish,
that sort of thing.
Although they actually really,
really dig this nasty little fish called
a midshipman.
Um,
which is this.
It looks like a,
the ugliest catfish you've ever seen.
And here's a pro tip for you.
The best bait to catch a leopard shark
is what was ever in the previous leopard
sharks.
Stomach.
Just Bait your hook up with whatever was
in his stomach.
And then you will absolutely catch
another leopard shark.
And this is the mid shipment.
Yeah,
midshipman strange looking fish as well.
The other good thing about them is not
only to the sharks love them,
but they stay on the hook forever,
that they like have a thick outer shell
or something and see the luminescent
dots on the bottom and that's pretty
cool.
Wow.
What a cool looking thing.
How big those things get well about like
that,
but that's it.
So they're essentially just tiny bait
fish you can get maybe 10 inches long.
Maybe.
What a cool looking fish though.
That's so prehistoric looking as a
little way I can get to skate.
He would go back to that other thing
again.
Yeah.
Look at that thing.
That's a little bioluminescent dots
underneath it.
So in deep deep water,
that thing that's all visible.
It's like racing stripes and all those.
A tricked out sports cars,
you know,
the maximum.
Like my sneakers,
like if you ran either these things like
you see them at night.
Oh I think when I'm talking about.
Yeah.
Well they reflect.
So that's cool.
Well that actually is like luminescent
though.
It's not it.
It reflects light.
Yeah,
it actually exudes light.
Right.
Wow.
That's a trip.
That's.
I am as fascinated by the ocean as any
other part of the world and I just think
it's so incredible that we've only
explored like 92 percent or something
ridiculous like that.
I think 90 something percent is unknown,
unexplored,
so strange.
You go look at that thing.
But it's funny.
I mean I'm known as the Game Guy,
right?
But I've spent most of my life dealing
with fish and shellfish and seafood and
I only started hunting when I was 30.
That's interesting.
Yeah.
Adult onset hunting as many people call
it right now.
Um,
when you,
when you cook something like a,
uh,
like a shark or anything that's
controversial,
anything along those lines?
Do you feel like you have to preface it
with some sort of an explanation that
this is not endangered species and
they're just a giant misconception and
this is no different than eating a tuna
or I usually put a paragraph or
something in there to say when you're
writing something and you'd be like,
hold on people,
this is not,
you know.
Yeah.
So the white shark,
it's not,
you know,
it's not an endangered species at all.
I mean just,
you don't,
I'll usually put a link to the,
the word says you can,
is the International Union of concern
whatevers and it's basically,
it's the,
it's the marker that shows what's
endangered,
what's threatened with a species of
concern.
And you know,
even then if you think about it,
our,
our bag limit for leopard sharks in the
San Francisco Bay is three a day and we
typically do a self imposed limit of
only two a day.
And we almost never keep females.
When you say we,
meaning you and your friends now,
most of the commercial fishing fleet in
a like,
so if you could take a charter and the
commercial,
like recreational charter charter boats,
they'll typically like,
do you need three fish?
Like you can have for three fish.
But there it's sort of strongly
encouraged just,
you know,
oh that's cool.
Just take the two and we're going to
throw these,
these big giant females back because a
lot of times,
especially this time of year,
they,
uh,
they can have pups because they give
birth to live young and nobody wants to,
you know,
open up a shark.
That's got little pups inside.
That's just wrong.
Have you ever seen that?
Is it an x ray or a sonogram of sharks
with the baby?
Sharks in their stomach.
Now know this,
but most people don't know.
Probably the sharks do
what you say.
You have live young inside of them,
but they're like these.
I put it up on my instagram because it
looks.
It's so crazy looking that it looks
fake.
It's like they'll little monsters living
inside this,
this other sharks body.
See if you can find that.
Well,
if you look at a human fetus for days,
look at that.
It isn't his mouth going open.
Oh yeah,
but there's images of it that's better.
Jamie.
There's A.
There's some.
Yeah,
that's it.
Can get a look at what it,
what it looks like.
I mean,
that's fucking crazy.
I mean that's what that.
And some of them eat their fellow
brothers and sisters inside the womb,
like they'll eat the weaker ones.
That's why you shouldn't have more than
five kids,
but what the fuck?
How do they eat?
And they're eating inside a womb.
Like what kind of a monster is a shark
that they can eat while they're in the
womb and they have teeth already.
They have fangs.
Well,
yeah.
Our human babies of teeth when they're
born,
don't they?
No,
no,
that's right.
They don't know.
You don't have kids do?
No,
not that I know of.
He skated through pass the breeding
point.
I'm pretty sure that we'll do a 45 or
46.
Did you come close at anytime?
Not that I know of.
No.
Good for you.
There's plenty of picking fucking
people.
That's one thing people with kids will
try to tell you like that.
Everybody needs kids.
Like I have kids.
Let me tell you something.
Everybody doesn't need kids.
There's plenty of people.
You can be a wonderful contributing
member to our culture and society
without reproducing.
Yup.
It's nonsense.
It's not everybody's path.
But one thing about babies is they don't
eat other babies while they're in the
womb that,
you know,
I have to do absorb them though,
don't they?
Like some weird twins.
Oh.
Which is weird.
Weird.
A Siamese twins where one twin will
absorb the other one.
Then they'll find like a tooth in the
babies.
I've heard about that dermoid,
Ooh,
what's a good name for it?
Be Good enough for a kid.
What's your name?
Dermoid.
But there are a lot of meals now that
people look up,
look down upon,
and that's becoming one of them,
right?
Sharks,
sharks coming.
One of them.
Squirrels and other ones.
Girls mostly.
Mostly,
uh,
urban,
urban and people like to make fun of
rural people for eating squirrels.
It's a sign of like,
oh,
you must be a hick.
Well,
if you go to,
there's a park in north Hollywood that a
near where I used to live and you can go
there and feed them peanuts.
It's kind of cool.
They come right up to you.
You just lay down.
As long as you're laying down,
this girl's would literally lay down and
hold up a peanut and the squirrels will
literally come up to you and take a
peanut.
And people feel bad about that.
Like we have weird rules about what
animals we like and what animals we
don't.
Because if it was a rat that came over
and took your peanut,
you'd be freaking out and there's not a
whole lot of difference between squirrel
and a rat.
The tail dude and adorable.
And it sticks up.
It looks like it's talking to you.
Tree tree rat with a good pr.
Good pr and something about fuzziness.
We'll,
we'll let them in.
Come on in.
Come on in as long as you just plants,
you know,
which is not true.
Apparently there's a,
uh,
a
video of a squirrel.
They caught eating some sort of a
mammal,
a mouse or something like that.
Eggs all the time to do that.
Like ground nesting birds as well.
They go into a tree and tree.
Yeah.
Oh Wow.
There it is.
Look at this fucking squirrel.
Then this mouse like python rabbit.
This is so crazy like this happen.
You know,
ground squirrels in California.
Uh,
there are guys.
I don't,
I haven't done it,
but they're,
these guys will go out and shoot ground
squirrels and then keep that up.
Like when Louis,
when you shoot Louie,
Joe comes out of this hole and grabbed
and eatsa.
Oh Jesus,
I,
it's a little horrible.
Instantaneously.
They just started.
I never liked you anyway,
you know?
I mean,
it's horrible.
There's a ranch that I go to to hone
ranch.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
And uh,
to hone ranch.
The guy who,
one of the guys was a guide there,
told me that the biomass,
this is a morbid senior,
get his square.
We're sitting here talking while the
squirrel is eating intestines is pretty
much an entire mouth.
Oh my God.
And he's going off to the bio mass of
ground squirrels.
Is He a ground squirrel?
He must be right.
It looks like it was a little squirly
tail.
He does look like a ground squirrel.
Yeah.
Squirrel.
A little bastard.
I'm the biomass of ground squirrels is
more than any other animal on the ranch
is 270,000
acres with mountain lions,
deer,
elk,
pigs,
and there's more weight of ground
squirrels and anything else.
And it was,
I would love to be able to tell you
that.
Yeah,
they're delicious,
but they tend to carry bubonic plague,
which does not make them good.
Eats.
Yeah.
You can eat regular squirrels.
Be Kenny,
ground squirrels.
Tree squirrels.
Yes.
Ground squirrels.
Now,
what is the difference in the species?
Are they interchangeable or the hybrids
ever?
No,
they're totally different species.
And uh,
uh,
the western gray tree squirrel is
really,
really big.
He's over two pounds and he's kind of a
very cold slate.
Gray and it's actually quite good.
Good hitting squirrel.
Um,
there used to be a very high limit on
him here in California,
but when Southeast Asian immigrants,
the mom came,
so the mom are very fond of squirrel
hunting and so it was a big thing what
they did back in Southeast Asia.
And so when they caught here,
they're like Suede or all these
squirrels and I guess they shot them out
because they,
uh,
the limits were 10 in the seventies and
early eighties.
Now they're just for a,
which is fairly low.
Uh,
you know,
for example,
in some of the Appalachian States is 10.
So That's interesting.
The moms,
I've heard that before there a big
hunting community.
Yeah.
The of the,
uh,
the recent immigrants to this country,
the two homos hunting as groups or the
Hmong and the Russians.
Hmm,
interesting.
And when I say Russians,
Russians,
Ukrainians,
Moldovans,
you know,
do they have a preference for like what
they
go after more?
I know the Russians have been putting a
hurt on our sturgeon up north sturgeon.
Yeah.
Interesting.
And it's mostly poaching and fishing
game is having a hard time getting a
handle on it now.
Do they like sturgeon for the caviar?
For the meat?
Yeah,
for the caviar.
So mean,
but that would have to be a female.
So how do you differentiate when you
catching them a.
well you can use and they're pretty slow
there.
They're pretty calm,
slow fish.
So it's pretty easy to determine if it's
a male or a female.
Um,
and if it's,
it looks sort of,
they call it gravity,
but um,
it looks pregnant if it's a big female.
And the other thing is I'm there almost
almost always oversized fish so we're
allowed three a year in California
legally and they have to be,
oh I'm gonna forget this,
I think it's 40 to 60 inches from the
fork of the tail.
Um,
that might be a slightly off,
but that's basically the legal.
How the lyrics is that legal size is 40
inches.
Oh yeah.
You have to catch something 40 inches.
Well,
that's a big ass state records I think.
Eight and a half feet long.
Wow.
In California?
Yeah.
It's either eight or 10.
It's huge.
The state record was caught by a dude
and a in Vallejo.
He caught it in the Carquinez straits
and like,
um,
I want to say the eighties,
but judging by the haircut now where are
they?
Are you catching them in deep water?
Like how you can catch them in
Sacramento.
You can catch the Calusa.
You can catch them in the delta.
Reverse.
What are the end?
Yeah,
they're in rivers there and then they go
out into the bay.
Wow.
But the general place you're going to
fish for them is going to be the delta
at Antioch,
at a San Pablo Bay,
that kind of area.
Now these sturgeon are.
Are they biting hooks?
Are you snagging them now?
They're nearby.
They're biting hooks.
What do they get?
What they feed.
So depending on who you talk to,
there's a friend of mine named j Dot
Lopes who runs a guide service or um,
he's a specialist in sturgeon and he
really loves cured Salmon Roe.
Uh,
so,
and he's got some special thing that he
does with the Salmon Roe,
but some people use ghost shrimp,
some people use cut herring.
Um,
they'll eat all kinds of stuff.
The largest freshwater fish on record
for California is a white sturgeon
caught by Joey Palato,
the huge fish waiting.
Amazing.
Four hundred and 68 pounds.
Whoa.
That's a big fucking fish,
man.
That's amazing.
The story of that fish is pretty
hilarious too because he can,
he's a,
he was working these cutoff work at,
you know,
so I think it was June or July.
Yeah.
So it was still,
it was still light out late.
So he caught this fish after work and he
couldn't get the damn thing in.
So he's like,
it's dragging them all around the
Carquinez straits and I guess he gets on
another boat like mid catch and it was a
bigger boat that could actually control
it because the sturgeon was just
dragging up and down and it's just the
story.
If you find the story of it,
it's just hilarious and that it.
And I'll look at the size of it and it
is a story that will end that,
that fish will never be broken because
that's a.
That would be an illegal fish right now.
Why is it illegal?
Because you're not allowed to land
anything bigger than 60 inches from the
fork of the tail.
Oh Wow.
Well how the fuck you gonna measure
that?
Like what if it's like hold on,
get the fish close.
I'm gonna.
Get Out of the ruler.
Like if it's a.
If it's close,
you just cut the lawn.
Well now if it's closed you can.
They're really survivable fish.
They don't die easy.
So you can.
I think you bring them on board.
You bring them on board,
measure them and then thrown back.
Huh?
Now,
is that a good fish to eat outside of
the row?
I love sturgeon.
How do you eat it?
A sturgeon again,
I would say if you've never eaten
sturgeon,
imagined swordfish.
Oh,
it's a lot like that.
No kids.
It's a signature dish of Sacramento
cuisine actually.
So if you go to restaurants in
Sacramento,
you will see sturgeon.
Oliver,
our menus,
people don't know about Sacramento.
Sacramento is so different than
California in terms of like how it is
la.
People think or you know,
San Diego.
People think Sacramento might as well be
like Iowa.
MMM.
Not in a bad way.
I mean,
I'm not.
I love Iowa.
I mean,
I mean in terms of like the hunting and
fishing and the outdoors,
people know
it's more like the twin cities.
Oh,
okay.
That's a good way to put it.
Yeah,
like a Minnesota.
Yeah.
Yeah,
that makes sense.
So here's a stat for you that I just,
my uh,
my girlfriend holly told me as she was
doing some research for a pr piece that
she was working on.
Ninety five percent of Californians are
urban.
Ninety five percent of California is
rural.
Oh,
in that crazy.
That is crazy.
Wow.
And over a third of the state is public
land.
Really?
Wow.
It's,
it's remarkable.
And it's uh,
you know,
it's why stay here,
that whole public land,
private land,
things of
is something that I had literally no
knowledge of,
no interest in,
never discussed until I met Rinella.
And when Rinella started,
Steven Alan started explaining to me the
difference between public land and
private land and how it was all put in
place by Teddy Roosevelt and all the
conservation that was done in the 18
hundreds and how much resistance was
behind it.
And he actually talked about a pretty in
depth and I podcast,
we did hear a couple of weeks ago and
uh,
I just,
I can't believe it took me until I was
like 45 until I heard about that.
Uh,
it's,
you know,
Steve's got a really good example of why
you might not necessarily have to.
It was because he was talking at the
back country hunters and anglers and he
had,
he used to live in Brooklyn.
[inaudible] weirdly.
Well,
his wife was working there.
I know just when I met him,
he was still kind of odd,
but uh,
it is,
he's about as Michigan as you get.
Yeah.
Um,
and so he was like,
yeah,
well everybody in New York City knows
can cite you chapter and verse the
subway lines.
No one who's doesn't have reason to,
has any reason to know about the subway
lines.
So when somebody who lives in rural
Montana or whatever,
says,
why haven't you ever know this issue
with public blah blah,
but well,
if
I live in New York City there,
I don't have to know.
Um,
and it's just like we got,
we were saying at the beginning of this,
it's like there's too many things to
look at.
There's too many distractions in our
world right now and it's just,
it makes it hard to do anything anymore.
There's no quiet at all in our lives
anymore.
Most people's lives.
Yeah.
That's,
Steve's got a real good way of breaking
things down like that.
He's,
he's got a good way of providing you
with examples that you go,
oh yeah,
that,
that's a good one,
you know,
because yeah,
if you lived in Montana you wouldn't
give a shit about the subway lines at
Brooklyn and if you lived in Brooklyn,
the infringing on public lands or Paul
Ryan's plan to sell them off to
corporations so that they could pay off
the debt.
It doesn't even register.
Well,
here's a good one for ya.
So depending on where you live,
like most of us call it public land.
Other people call it government land was
a very different connotation.
Yeah,
because the government land means it's
not ours,
but it's really ours.
Right?
So if you call it government land,
seems like,
well if they sell it,
it's not yours anyway,
but it actually is yours,
which is that,
that is a weird one that takes a while
to absorb.
Like the land is actually the own.
We've the people of the United States or
the owners of the land.
Right?
So if you go hunting on public land
Europe,
you know the background of your hunch.
Back country hunters and anglers shirts,
they have,
it says public landowner.
I love that shirt because we're all
public land doors.
If you paid taxes,
you live in America,
you own public land.
Similarly,
all the game on everybody's playing in
public or private.
Yeah.
Belongs to the ease of the people in the
United States or if its migratory,
the people of Canada,
the United States and Mexico,
or if you're in Texas and it's a high
fence,
that's legally livestock.
Yeah.
That's weird.
Right?
That's.
That's a strange distinction.
The difference between public land and
private land and the animals being on
it.
Even if it's private land,
those animals are owned by people.
Right.
By the people reading publishes.
Why we actually have deer.
Yeah.
That's the only reason why.
Well,
that large scale agriculture,
the populations are higher than ever
before and all that good stuff.
Actually,
it's.
There's a great book called dear land
that talks about why if you go to the
northeast,
they're overrun with white tails because
white tails like the edges between field
and forest.
It's suburbia.
Is there perfect habitat for it?
Yeah.
Well,
and the problem that goes with that is
of course deer ticks and lyme disease,
which is run rampant through the
northeast.
It's just stayed as it.
Yeah.
Steve has it.
His son has it and they are amongst two
people out of,
I don't know,
maybe 10 that I've ever met that had
been misdiagnosed.
I had this Guy Steven Kotler on here the
other day who was misdiagnosed for a
year,
for one fucking year,
and because of that it got so deep into
his system that he was in bed for three
years in the hospital.
Oh Man.
He was hospitalized for three fucking
years from lyme disease.
Morale is a horror story.
It's so scary.
You know,
when you talk to people that have had
it,
and one of the really fascinating things
about Steve,
he's really smart.
Steven Kotler,
and when he was discussing it,
he was talking about the neurological
aspects of lyme disease,
that it really wreaks havoc on your
cognitive function.
To the point where one time when he had
it before he was diagnosed,
he didn't know what was wrong with him.
He was at a green light and he couldn't
figure out what green met.
Oh Wow.
Then he couldn't figure out how to drive
his car.
He had a stick shift.
He could not figure out how to do it
anymore.
He didn't know how to drive his car like
in the middle of driving.
He forgot how to drive it and it was
like,
oh my God,
they're going crazy.
There's something wrong with me.
Like bad.
And that's like right before,
I believe you said it was right before
they checked him into the hospital and I
bet pumped him full of IV antibiotics
and figured out exactly what it was when
I play it ticks on me.
But you know,
knock on wood,
I've never had your line,
man.
I wish there was a way to stop it.
Like I wish there doesn't seem to be
any.
I think it's in California in
particular,
it's misdiagnosed a lot because it's not
here yet.
It is.
They found it in Mendocino,
but it's not in like math.
Yeah.
And in the east coast,
they think something like,
I think they were talking about,
I think they were talking about long
island where they were saying some
absurd number,
like 50 percent of the ticks of lyme
disease.
There's something crazy.
I went mushroom hunting to summer ago,
Sogo with,
um,
a fellowship friend of mine and Anita
Lo.
And uh,
so we were at a meeting and by her place
in eastern end of Long Island and uh,
you know,
it took some mushrooms,
had a good time,
blah,
blah blah.
So I get back like 48 hours later I find
to tick nymphs right the right the band
of my boxers and like,
oh shit.
And so I immediately rush to the doctor
and I got that day the basically they
give you a three pack of Cipro and he'd
go boom,
boom,
boom.
And try and knock it out and seemed to
work to get it quicker.
Yeah,
you got to get it really quick.
Those little fuckers we see.
I did this show for Scifi called Joe
Rogan questions,
everything.
And one of the things that we're,
we investigated was this weird disease
called more Jaylen's.
Have you ever heard of this?
And not by that name.
Well,
it's a weird.
They think it's a psychosomatic disorder
where these people believe there's
something wrong with them,
but there's not.
And they have these parts of their body
where they just itch incessantly and
they can't stop and then they believe
fibers are growing out of their body and
they'll get like um,
carpet hairs in there and they think
that it's growing out of their body,
you know,
carpet fibers and they're convinced.
But one of the guys that I interviewed
was a doctor who also had more jealous
and what he,
he had a really unique insight to it
because he said that as a doctor,
one of the things that he found,
this is a direct correlation between
people who have this disease and lyme
disease.
They almost all have lyme disease.
And he thinks it was really going on is
that peep.
And this is a guy who was talking about
his own,
like his brain malfunctioning on him.
He was saying that people who have lyme
disease,
that there is some sort of a neuro toxic
effect of lyme disease,
which distorts reality to the point
where these people think these fibers
are growing out of them and he was
talking about himself like he had saw
something moving around in his eye,
like saw something wiggling around on
the surface of his eye and then it
wasn't there anymore and he realized
like,
okay,
this is not real.
Like I'm seeing something that's not
real.
And then as he got deeper into it,
he found that all these people that had
this bizarre morgellons thing also had
lyme disease.
Make sense?
I mean,
if you,
if you know,
you know about the symptoms of
toxoplasmosis where we should make some
mice really dig cats.
Yeah.
Well it makes them sexually attracted to
cat urine.
People don't know what we're talking
about.
Google,
Robert Sapolsky from Stanford University
in Northern California,
but try and get that guy on for years.
He's just so not a publicity whore.
He just,
I can't get them on.
I'm like,
I'll fly to you,
dude.
He's like,
I'm busy.
I'm like,
fuck,
he's.
I'm an expert in.
While he does a lot of primate work too,
it does a lot of work with baboons and
stuff too,
but he's the foremost expert in the
United States of toxoplasmosis and the
effects of it.
It gets,
it gets them horny for cat urine.
It literally changes the.
The sexual hard wiring of a rat gets it
horny for cat urine.
They literally get erections and they go
running around near Cath.
They're not scared of cats,
takes away their fear.
The cats eat them,
and because of that it gets into people.
The cats around it doesn't seem to
effect the cat's behavior.
The cats are just carriers and then it
gets into people,
makes people more aggressive.
It makes people more prone to get in
accidents.
Disproportionate amount of motorcycle
victims,
motorcycle crash victims have
toxoplasmosis thing.
That's what's the polsky pointed out
when he was doing his residency,
they did some.
He was doing some work in emergency
rooms and one of the surgeons was saying
there's a disproportionate amount of
motorcycle victims that have Toxoplasma,
so when a motorcycle victim would come
in,
they would test them for toxo
interestingly talks,
I was one of the few diseases you can
pick up from deer.
Really.
How do you get it from deere?
Uh,
I'm not entirely sure.
I think it's contact or eating
undercooked venison,
but it's very rare.
It's actually,
I think there's only been like six cases
in the last 20 years that the CDC
reports.
But ironically there's a guy who,
who,
um,
is on the facebook forum that I run was
one of the sex.
Oh,
what?
What are the odds?
Right.
And he's like,
well,
you know,
I'm one of these guys.
And it was,
it,
it messed him up pretty bad.
In what way would you say they're doing
a lot of the same?
A lot of the same symptoms that you were
talking about,
you know,
risk taking risk,
taking it,
any aggressive behavior,
blood problems too.
Like I can't,
I can't remember for the life of me,
but it was,
you know,
like his blood pressure spiked and it
was,
it was significant.
Well,
it's what people,
when they talk about crazy cat people,
that literally is what they're talking
about probably.
Yeah.
Oh,
the 60 percent of France at one point in
time had toxoplasma because of all the
roaming around.
They think they've gotten it down to as
low as like 35 percent.
Uh,
same as Brazil.
Brazil is somewhere around 40 percent,
40 percent plus of people that live
there have toxo.
There's also a disproportionate
connection between toxoplasmosis rates
of infection in infestation of infection
and successful soccer teams.
They're risk takers.
Yeah.
Well,
yeah.
Risk takers more aggressive.
It's very strange if you tested them and
maybe they also know,
again,
it would be off the chain,
your real problem,
but I'm fucking cat crazy,
bro.
I think there's also some sort of a
connection between sexual promiscuity
and females.
Hmm.
Yeah.
There's a lot of weird stuff they're
working on to try to figure out what
exactly these fucking Paris it's doing
to people's brains.
Well,
you've heard of the courthouse steps,
right?
Yes.
Yeah.
Make the Zombie ants.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
Well,
there's good.
There's good strains of quarter step
stool to climb to the top of that leaf.
Well,
the.
This is what people don't know.
What you're trying to talk about is
there's a mushroom that infects the
spores.
In fact,
an ant convinced the ant to go some
linear high so that these cordyceps
mushrooms grow inside the antibody body
and then it explodes and sprays spores
through the air,
infecting all around.
It's so gnarly nature.
So not like if you watched the movie
like the movie alien.
So I don't know if this is 100 percent
true,
but I've always heard that that the
creature is a.
is a Mashup of real insects.
Is that the.
The bug.
Okay,
so this is this a dead one that has it
already as a timelapse.
So in the time lapse,
this mushroom is growing out of the back
of his aunt's head like this aunt has
been killed by this fungus and it's now
manifesting itself in this growing form.
That's not really a plant.
That's another thing that people
misconstrue about fungus.
It's actually closer to an animal than
it is to vegetation.
They they breathe oxygen and breathe out
carbon dioxide.
So this is some fucking freaky ass alien
life form.
It was growing out.
His aunts had look at the size of that
thing.
It's huge.
It's so gnarly.
Kills the ant and it grows mushrooms out
of it and then the spores blow up and.
Oh,
well that's cool.
That's so bizarre.
Look,
it's popping through its exoskeleton.
That's so creepy.
Like,
you know where Ridley Scott got it.
Oh yeah.
Well do you know about that aquatic worm
that infects grasshoppers?
No.
Oh,
this is a great one.
This aquatic worms.
I love how focused and direct our
conversation today.
So every one of them I do as a director
of my life,
but um,
these aquatic worms.
Uh,
or a.
What is it?
Chronic.
Yeah,
it's aquatic warm,
right?
Yeah.
Um,
it gets inside of grasshopper and this
is one infected a.
I'm a praying mantis and this one's
going to burst out of the praying
Mantis,
but when this aquatic worm gets,
oh,
because you get it wet,
that's what it'll.
It'll come out and.
But the aquatic worm that gets inside
grasshoppers,
when it reaches gestation,
when it reaches its,
uh,
it's,
it's when it's time to be born,
it rewires the grasshoppers brain and
talks the grasshopper into committing
suicide.
So the grasshopper jumps into a lake and
drowns and the aquatic worm comes out of
its body and swims away.
Like,
look at this thing that's so nasty.
Look at the size of this fucking thing
that was living inside this praying
mantis while it was alive.
So it takes over the mind of these,
these beings.
I mean,
look at this size of this thing.
it is a solid 30 to 40 percent,
maybe more of the mass of the body of
this.
It's so gnarly.
It's hard to believe when you look at
the size of this thing,
because it's continuing to come out the
grasshopper.
Let's just.
If we had a scale,
the grasshoppers maybe two inches long
mantis.
That's the man that meant this is
probably a solid four inches long.
Yeah.
I'm sorry.
Mantis.
So whatever length that is,
the aquatic worms three times that.
Yeah.
Which is just nuts and it's living in
its body and still coming out as we're
talking about auto.
It's a fucking huge man and he's trying
to find water that's gravitating towards
the water,
but with grass hopping on fire.
I know,
right?
That's evil.
We're lucky too little if,
uh,
if you find the grasshopper,
there's one where it talks the
grasshopper,
the grasshopper just jumps in,
the water just starts drowning and then
it pops out of its body and it's like
nature.
Such a creepy,
creepy thing.
And in a lot of ways,
like the parasite world in particular,
like somehow or another predators to me
are less disturbing than parasites.
Oh yeah.
Here's one that's coming out of it was a
cricket or something.
Could be.
Look at that creepy thing.
Yeah,
I'm aquatic worms.
not good.
Let's,
uh,
I want to talk to you about more
bizarrely edible of things that may be,
um,
a lot of people don't think of sturgeon
is one of them.
I didn't know.
I knew that people eat sturgeon eggs,
but I really wasn't aware that the
sturgeon was that delicious fish.
I also wasn't aware that it was illegal
to catch them.
Like I for some reason thought that they
were in danger.
It's weird.
Which is one of the reasons why poaching
is such a big issue is because we're one
of the last recreational fisheries in
the country for sturgeon.
Really?
Yeah.
Because the populations.
Because the um,
the east coast,
east coast sturgeon was fished out
around 100 years ago and they're only
now coming back in the east coast.
There's still no fishery for them.
So all of the sturgeon you've seen
restaurants in Sacramento is farmed.
Oh,
that's interesting.
So how do they farm a sturgeon slowly,
I would imagine.
I think they have to be seven years
before they can take it to market size.
So it's like making bourbon.
Yeah,
because I was reading like a,
what was another commercial fish they
were talking about the amount of time
that it takes to grow a commercial fish
to the point where you can harvest it
and it was some insane number,
like two inches a year where it takes
forever to grow these things to the
point,
I think it was catfish.
They were talking about like large
catfish.
That's what it was.
They were talking about what's going on
in the Ohio river that um,
they're,
they're putting these catfish in lakes
and they're taking them out of rivers,
are putting large cat fish in lakes,
but they can't survive,
can only live in these lakes for so
long,
but everybody wants to catch a big
catfish.
So they have these commercial cat
fishing businesses were recreational
catfishing with take these people and
they'll have them fishing in these lakes
and they used some sort of chemical in
the lake that forces the cat fish to
bite.
Yeah.
And this,
this chemical fish bordello yeah,
it's really gross man,
because it causes these legions on the
catfishes skin.
So these people catch these catfishes
and they have catfish rather sorry,
and they have these red sores all over
their body because some chemicals have
been introduced into the water,
which I guess the irritant causes them
to like they're biting out of
frustration.
I guess maybe the unspeakable in pursuit
of the inevitable.
What's is so bizarre.
Like what a strange choice that people
have decided.
Let's take this animal out there.
There's one with legions on it.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
We'll see.
Another issue rises on bigger catfishes
are introduced into pay lakes.
Yeah.
So legs.
They have these lakes.
So I didn't even know that.
I didn't even know there was a paleo.
Like look at the all the spots on that
one.
Look at the fucking spots on that day
and see you find what it says.
That chemical is that they dumped into
the water.
Just go to the river in Virginia.
You'll kitchen ice one.
I've caught 70 pounders.
Well in a river.
Really?
Yeah.
I mean how many of them are out?
Which,
which fish you catch blue fish.
A white cat.
A white cat because it's a big one.
Why cats bluecat's channel cats,
but yeah,
blues and whites are usually biggest.
Atlanta heads get really big too,
but they don't live in Virginia.
I don't think it's called juicing.
Okay.
The chemicals they put in the water make
the fish bite in the pe lake industry.
It's called juicing weird.
Look at the fucking lesions on that
thing.
Scroll up a little Jimmy backup.
Look at that.
The poor things body.
It's just wrong.
It's bizarre.
It's not just wrong.
I don't really understand how that ever
got past how people are like accepting
that.
Like that's a natural one.
The one below that.
This seems totally healthy that some got
caught from a river.
So these pay lakes is a is like,
I guess it's like a private land thing.
Somebody owns them and it just keeps
dumping these fish in there and
apparently they don't live there very
long.
They don't else fishing equivalent of a,
of a.
those little teeny high fence places you
see in the east.
You go hot,
go hunt elk on 40 acres.
Do they have those in the east coast?
Like so,
you know,
in Texas a lot of the high fence places
are thousands and thousands of acres,
but they have them in the,
in the Midwest and the east,
and sometimes they're painfully small,
you know,
like tens of acres where effectively,
you're shooting something in a pen.
I saw one that was 10 acres,
right?
It's on Ebay.
Yeah.
There were craigslist where this guy had
put up this hunt in quotes.
I'm doing air quotes for this enormous
buck that they had used for breeding on
this commercial,
dear property.
See if you own a piece of land and pro,
uh,
in Texas or in any place where they
allow this,
you can buy deer and then have these
deer released onto your land and then
you can air quotes again,
hunt them.
So they raised these things to maturity
and they give them this massive protein
rich diet.
And then they also have great genetics
on top of that.
So these deer have these insane antlers.
Franken buck of all.
They're so strange looking.
It's such a weird thing when you see
them and you know,
that is what a regular wild Colorado
mule deer it looks like.
It just looks normal.
It's like that's what you see.
Everybody recognizes it.
That's what it looks like when you see
one of those bizarre farm raised box.
It looks like they have bushes grown out
of.
It does.
It's really bizarre.
I don't even think it's attractive.
It's gross.
It doesn't,
it doesn't have that,
you know,
that classic line of a,
of a regular,
of a deer that is kind of,
I think is imprinted on our brains.
Yeah.
No,
I agree.
It's,
it's,
it's some weird thing like double e fake
boobs.
Right?
Like,
okay,
what are you doing?
Like you went,
you went crazy.
He went too far.
Like it is something that doesn't make
any sense anymore.
Yeah.
Um,
another fish that I wanted to ask you
about is what are you going?
What's up?
I found out what?
The juicing.
Okay.
What's the Chemical Hopper Selfie?
Oh.
So it says that it forces them to feed
and move excessively.
And then it also is used to like treat
vegetation.
And algae and other lakes kill an excess
that can kill fish too.
But it says it's designed to kill
unwanted lake vegetation.
Copper sulfate.
And it also used to be put in canned
green beans to keep them green.
Oh my God.
I wonder if it made people move around a
lot after the eight.
Fucking strange man.
God,
what kind of monster pours out into a
lake to get the fish to eat more?
Um,
I want to talk to you about Gar.
Have you ever had garfish?
I actually haven't.
I know guys who have,
um,
I know you have to pretty much clean it
with a hatchet.
And I know that everybody I know who's
eating Gar says is awesome.
Yeah,
I've heard smoked.
Gar is awesome.
Jamie.
That's a little tiny one pull up.
But yeah,
look,
there you go.
Yeah.
That is a crazy fish.
Has been around for what,
how many millions of years of thing,
but a lot for like over a hundred.
I totally primitive.
I mean it literally looks like some kind
of a fucking dinosaur fish.
And those are in Texas.
Natural Texas.
Oklahoma,
Arkansas.
Yeah.
Like Louisiana.
And can you catch those on a hooker?
Do you spear them or you can get them on
a hook?
What do they.
What do they have?
Wire?
Yeah,
you'd better have a lot of wire,
right?
Like those teeth,
if I remember right.
They like live bait.
Okay.
What an enormous fucking crazy,
weird animal.
There's a big.
Okay.
That's a perspective shot.
That's still.
That's probably an eight foot car.
What's a world record guard?
Let's tell you.
Guess I'm going to say gets to 12 feet.
Twelve feet.
That's going can be my guess.
Wow.
I'm going to go with 10.
You're probably right though.
New World record that says quick.
Twelve feet.
Let's find it on the web.
What is the world record?
Two hundred 79 pounds.
Wow.
How big is that?
How long is it?
200.
Seventy nine pounds caught in 1951.
That's the world record.
Yeah.
Whoa.
That's not from 1951.
And we'll get the size of that thing.
Oh,
alligator gar.
Now is there a difference between an
alligator Gar and a regular garden?
Yeah,
I think there's a couple of different
species.
Oh,
and you can eat them all.
Uh,
as far as I know.
So yeah,
that's another animal I didn't know that
you can eat these fish until I watched
one of those,
a crazy reality shows where people live
in the mountains in other one of those
subsistence shows bleed and we made
people animal.
Dick's never made people igar.
It's an literally as an armor plate on
the outside of it.
Right.
It's like you need like a hatchet to get
through it.
Yeah.
I've seen people cutting through them
with what looks like a salsa holds.
No,
it was what they were using was like
something you would trim branches off
loppers.
Just try to cut through that stuff.
40 seven inches and girth eight foot
five.
Oh my God.
That's a giant thing.
So,
but that's not a world record,
right?
That's just a giant one.
Hmm.
Ooh,
what a weird animal.
It's just strange to me also that some
animals figured out how to stay alive
like alligators and crocodiles for,
you know,
x amount of million years.
Well,
all these other things like large mouth
bass are like so much more recent and
these things swim amongst them.
You strange remnants of a much more
savage past like the coelacanth.
Yes.
That's a great one because that one they
thought until they caught one,
it was like the early 19 hundreds.
They thought it'd been extinct for
billions of years.
South Africa.
Yeah.
Now apparently like you can catch them
like there's,
you know,
there's a place where you can catch
them.
It's,
it's legal.
Well I think it's catch and release,
but it's uh,
but it's,
it's not that,
you know,
that was up coelacanth,
but when you catch them,
super common,
but it's not like a news event when the
catch one anymore.
Oh,
there's one right there.
Wow.
What a strange looking prehistoric
creature to actually.
I think honestly,
I think the gars more impressive.
That's bizarre looking.
But the um,
the coelacanth if it's,
is it a deep water fish?
Yeah.
It's a deep water section.
Now when you catch and release at deep
water fish,
aren't they fuck though?
Bringing them up through the top,
like rockfish hard in the Pacific.
They certainly are.
They don't have the eyeballs pop out of
their head.
That was weird.
But link cod don't.
Oh,
so if you catch a lean cod,
you can bring them up to the surface and
there is that a coelacanth and someone
caught on a hook to you.
It looks like it.
And so when you catch a link caught on a
hook,
you can just throw it back in the water
and even though it goes 500 feet,
never seen her link card with Ben's real
rockfish.
Always got them.
So it's just a matter of the frailty of
the,
uh,
it's just the way the fish has built,
I think,
you know,
and here I'm just guessing,
but um,
but link,
God will come from the,
from the bottom all the way up to the
top to hunt as a beautiful fish too.
Whereas bucket mouth,
God was cool looking fresh and delicious
too.
Big Old bucket.
Now that link,
odds are,
that's another one that looks like it's
not supposed to be alive anymore.
They're so awesome.
Lead biggest one I ever caught was a,
was a hitchhiker.
It had hit a rock fish brought the
rockfish,
just the surface and the link.
I wouldn't let go.
No Shit.
Gaff.
The linkcard wow.
That's interesting.
Twenty three pounds.
Well he wouldn't let go.
Nope.
Why does that go?
If you,
if you let a 10 break the water,
but if you keep it's head in the water,
it won't like that.
Oh.
So when head comes out of the water,
it's like,
oh,
this is bullshit.
Right?
He's like,
oh,
that's peculiar.
Look at the mouth of those fuckers blew
one.
Wow.
So do you like it?
Like that to be the last thing you saw?
Yeah,
that would suck.
It would be like tripping and hell
sucked into that vortex.
Yeah.
That looks like something from that
movie.
The event horizon,
when the demons taking over the
spaceship like sucked into that.
Yeah.
The teeth on that fucker.
This is a hard ass world.
That thing lives in done.
Don't let them when you catch him.
Oh yeah.
Right.
Yeah.
You gotta grab that thing around the
gills or gaffers and what is all that
we're looking at here?
Uh,
he's gutting.
It was strange stomach looking.
Yeah,
they turn blue like that.
It's,
Oh,
I used to know they turn blue because of
what they eat and I think it's like
salmon when you buy commercial salmon
and they have to die the skin because
they're not eating the same kind of
bugs.
Yeah.
Well farmed farmed Atlantic Salmon.
Um,
well they're eating.
The red is from Krill.
Excuse me.
Blue caught.
Okay.
So this is hilarious.
So I've seen this article extremely
rare,
blue cod cod in Australia,
which is a.
okay.
So it was explained to me that they are
extremely rare in Alaska.
Is that say Alaska Australia?
Scroll up.
Alaska,
but they're incredibly common where I
live.
Oh.
I once I once hooked into 13 lingcod
and one fishing trip and six of them
were blue.
Whoa.
So,
and this is all off the northern
California closes off the Marin Sonoma
coast and that's a great area to fish,
right?
It is,
but it's like not extremely rare.
Apparently up.
They're there if they're rare,
but it has to do with their diet.
Okay.
So maybe that it migrate from up there
all the way up to Alaska native,
their native all the way up to Alaska.
So that the really biggest ones or if
you catch them in the Alaska.
Oh really?
50 pounders.
Yeah,
the ones that would eat a toddler.
Well,
Alaska has those Goddamn halibut that
are like our doors giant.
So I was sort of sad because I went up
there because I wanted to catch a giant
and then I was reading about it before
and I realize that every,
every halibut over about 125 pounds is
big breeding female.
So it's a bad idea to land it because
actually the halibut stocks and Alaska's
are not doing that well.
So get to the surface,
get a picture of it.
So your ideal halibut,
apparently it's like an 80 pounder or 85
pounder.
That's plenty big,
which is plenty big and it's not
necessarily big breeding female.
And so you're not really going to hurt
the species is like,
like,
like the guys who keep the 400 pounders.
Absolutely.
And the weird thing about fish breeding
behavior is that it's,
it's exponential.
So a buddy of mine,
a guy named Jay Waldron,
uh,
he landed 53 pounds,
striper in the delta.
Um,
actually it was a,
it was a fishing buddy and they tried
and tried and tried and tried to revive
it,
but it just,
it died,
which sucked.
Um,
and,
and then,
but it was that thing there would be
like the supermom for thousands and
thousands and thousands of stripers
Morales.
An 18 inch striper that was a female
would not be.
It's not linear.
It's not like they get a little bit
more,
they get exponentially better,
you know,
they get,
did have exponentially more breeding
power as they get bigger and bigger and
bigger.
So it's generally not a good idea to,
to eat our seed corn even if they're
fish.
Wow.
Um,
I had a friend of mine of cotton,
enormous halibut on a boat.
It was one of those,
a charter boats,
fishing boats and calmer when they were
pulling it up.
They cut the line on him and he was so
pissed off.
He's like,
they were trying to tell them like,
look,
you can't keep this one.
It was huge.
It was like I go how big,
and he's like more than 300 pounds we
have.
I don't even know how big it took
forever to bring in,
but once we got it to the surface,
they wanted to cut the line.
They let it go and he was so pissed off.
He just the right thing to do
biologically.
It makes sense.
It totally makes sense and is such a
cool looking animal to like what a bus
train.
Glad that fucker.
Yeah,
that one's too big.
Two hundred 55 pounds.
They fucked up.
They shouldn't have killed that one.
Right?
I wouldn't know.
I mean it's,
it's legal.
It's not illegal,
but it's supposed to do it because the
stocks are.
They're okay,
but they're not doing super great
because the chances are the in the next
dropdown
you're going to get to 75 pounder
anyway.
Right?
So really there's Jesus.
You see the ones in the right.
That's what you should be keeping.
The two 87.
I'd let that go because think about it.
How much hell,
but are you going to eat really?
Right?
I mean,
yeah,
I know most guys are gonna go up to
Alaska once a year,
so.
But still those other ones are in the
seventies.
It was easily three or four of those in
the 70 pound range.
Two hundred and 87 pound fish is a big
ass fucking Fishman.
And the,
the flake,
the flake on those big halibut is so big
that it's,
it gets so coarse that they're not.
They're okay.
I mean they taste fine,
but the,
they're harder to cook.
When my oldest daughter was,
I guess she was like 12,
somewhere around there,
12 or 13,
she,
she's real sensitive.
She's very sweet person and she wanted
to be a vegetarian and uh,
you know,
and she was a vegetarian for a while.
Then she started eating meat again,
but she always loves animals and I said,
well listen,
let's go fishing.
And this is before I ever hunted.
I'm like,
let's go fishing.
We'll catch a fish and we'll cook it.
And it's a kind of a cool experience
because you get to experience catching
something,
cooking it.
So we went out on his boat five minutes
into the trip.
We catch a fucking Marlin.
All right.
And Are you fishing Hawaii?
Oh,
we're in Hawaii and five minutes in we,
we,
it's not a big Marlin.
It's about a 70 pound Marlin.
Um,
it takes a while to get an onboard.
We get on board and then the guys who
run the boat beat this thing to death in
front of her with a club because that's
what you do.
You get a Marlin on board,
you beat it to death.
Why?
That's the only way to stop it from
flopping around.
And why would they kill it needed?
Oh,
they eat them.
Okay.
Yeah,
they smoke them apparently.
Okay.
But that was another thing I thought
Marlin's aren't good.
I'm glad you just said that because the
most recent trip that I had,
I was in Hawaii just a month ago and
that's the only state I've never been
to.
Oh my God,
you got to go.
That's a magic place.
That's a real.
I think Hawaii has an energy that when
you get off the plane,
he goes,
oh,
we're here.
Like it's got a feel to it because
you're on a fucking volcano.
A volcano in the middle of the ocean.
I mean,
that's really what it is.
Sure.
Volcano popped at me.
You could.
We took a helicopter where you fly over
the volcano as it leaks into the ocean.
You see the steam coming up as the lava
is flowing.
It's amazing.
Anyway,
they pulled me.
She's such a sweet kid.
She's so sensitive and friendly and nice
and they beat this fucking and Marlin to
death in front of her and then they're
covering it with bags of ice and they're
all psyched and it's making all these
weird noises and then like,
she just starts to calm down and get
over it and then 20 minutes later start
flopping again.
It's not totally dead.
I've never been able to take her fishing
since she's 20 now.
She's like,
fuck you,
fuck you dad.
What did you do?
And I'm like,
honey,
this is where we get fished.
This were from,
it was the size of a dog.
It was like,
you know,
a dog size thing.
It was,
it wasn't like we brought in,
you know,
a 12 inch trout.
Right.
It was a giant ass living creature that
these guys beat to death.
I mean,
it's a small boat.
They,
they beat it to death five feet from
her,
so five feet away they're beaten this
thing with club.
Wow.
Yeah.
And I just kind of dramatic.
It was very dramatic.
It was.
So that was the end of that.
We've talked about taking her hunting,
but I don't think,
I think still that fucking one Marlin
messes with her.
Um,
but they were telling me that you had to
smoke it.
But on the last trip that I was on,
which was about a month ago,
these guys were telling me that.
No,
no,
no.
You can cut it and eat it.
Like swordfish.
Yeah.
He cut it and grill.
No reason why you couldn't.
Have you ever had.
You've ever had it though?
I've never actually said why were you
saying why would you keep Marlin?
Because almost nobody does.
Like you didn't like if you go to Costa
Rica or Baja or the Caribbean,
they're caught in a catch and release.
Only do that to ensure the population.
I think they do.
I mean,
because I've,
I've,
I've heard that the Hawaiians Cedam but
I've eaten it and it's just.
But yeah,
I mean almost all Marlin fishing is
catch and release.
That's interesting.
Yeah.
That's a,
that's the big trophy fish,
right?
That's the one that they want.
I've never caught one wall.
That was the only time I ever caught one
and then we caught it maybe 10 minutes
into fishing.
Swordfish.
Get that big.
Yeah.
But that one's coming over the rail.
That's delicious fish right now.
You think that takes a significantly
different than a Marlin?
I bet they're pretty similar.
I would like to know why I was wanting
to ask you about God because I've always
wanted to go golf fishing because I've
seen them and when you see those images
that we just looked at like,
God damn,
I want to see that thing in real life.
I would wish to.
You had tried it.
I've tried a lot of things.
Yeah.
How have you not both in paddlefish is
an interesting one.
Right?
That's a Sacramento fish too,
is now.
That's a Missouri River thing.
They're cousins of the sturgeon.
Oh,
okay.
And that's one that doesn't really have,
um,
they don't have any bones,
right?
Either.
Just sturgeon.
Oh really?
Oh.
So sturgeon's law like a shark in that
sense.
Yeah.
But start sharks have bones only around
the jaw right now.
There's also some weird thing with a
paddlefish where you pull that spinal
cord out of them right now.
What a weird looking fucking thing that
is.
They're pretty tasty though.
That's what I hear.
And uh,
if you've ever had lump fish caviar,
that's what that is.
No,
I've never.
What is a lump fish caviar caviar out of
a paddle fish?
I don't know why they call it paddle
fish,
but they should just call it paddlefish
caviar,
which I think they are now.
Something about the restrictions on
commercial paddle fishing because I
don't think there is.
No,
I think it's all recreational now.
And then some states,
wow,
that looks like a fake animal.
It doesn't even look real football fish.
But I think that concern was about the
caviar.
Right?
So there was again,
um,
there was uh,
an illegal trade in,
in uh,
and paddlefish caviar.
So there are some states where you can
keep your fish,
but fish and game keeps the caviar.
Really.
How bizarre.
That's not.
I don't think that's pretty good.
I don't think that's cool.
I think it should be illegal to sell,
but like in Missouri,
Missouri fishing game.
Keep the caviar.
What are they going to do this?
They sell it.
Oh,
that's even weirder.
Yeah,
that's really weird.
Well,
I wouldn't,
I mean it probably.
I would,
I would hope I'm,
you know,
missourians will,
will,
will tell us,
but I would hope that the proceeds from
selling the caviar by fish fishing game
would go back to it.
Like habitat restoration or something.
I would hope so too.
But I would hope so that you could pay
like an additional tag and get to keep
the caviar.
I'm saying he caught a female and he pay
an extra $30 or something like that.
And You keep the caviar.
I know you can't in some states like
Montana for sure.
You can.
In Montana,
like what?
They have paddlefish in Montana.
Yeah.
They're all a giant rivers,
like name of big giant river in the
middle of the country and they live
there.
That's,
it looks like another one that just made
it through.
It did evolution.
Yeah.
How long has that fucker been?
Around?
One hundred million years.
Easy.
There's a show on tv,
I forget the name of it,
but it's this guy who,
uh,
who cooks weird stuff on like the
sportsmans channel.
Oh,
that's got les sap dead meat.
Yeah.
Scott.
Scott lives like one to 10 miles from my
house.
That's what I was going to bring him up
because he's a sacramento.
Yeah.
And he cooked paddlefish.
Yep.
That's what he,
he like,
he pulled the spinal cord out of him.
He's got an interesting show.
He takes everything.
He has the one of the best self
deprecating sense of humor ever.
Ever.
Yeah.
That's hilarious.
I mean he's on the dates on the road 300
days a year.
Really?
Yeah.
He does a lot of stuff for like,
um,
a group called hunt fish feed.
So it's gets hundreds together to,
to donate tons and tons of game meat for
homeless shelters.
And they do big like a big cookout thing
so that everybody gets a meal.
Oh,
that's cool.
That's cool stuff.
Yeah.
But he's found a lot of fish and a lot
of game that people thought was inedible
actually turns out to be quite
delicious.
I'll tell you one that he didn't python.
Oh really?
Not Good.
He said it was like main landing.
Mercury.
Whoa.
He said it was the worst thing he's ever
put in his mouth.
Wow.
Yeah.
Python.
Python in the everglades.
Huh?
Did he try to do anything with it?
Marinated?
I think he tried it every which way,
but Sunday.
And he just like,
no,
none of it here.
Do you know how do you know when you're
eating something like that?
Whether or not it's actually edible?
Well,
I think you can do some,
like allbirds are edible.
For example.
Allbirds.
Yeah,
some disgusting and fishy.
But uh,
and most mammals are edible,
but like,
you know,
the livers on polar bears have so much
vitamin A,
it'll kill you if you eat them.
Really?
Yeah.
So don't need polar bear liver.
Just just the dude I was about to pro
tip another protest to show folks what a
show.
I know.
It's like so random it polar bears and
odd,
right?
That's a.
that's a strange animal in that it's
just 100.
It's a bear,
but it's 100 percent carnivorous.
There's not a vegetable to be seen up
there and it's adapted.
I've seen him eat seaweed on TV.
Really?
Yeah.
I think.
I think it's because they're freaking
out because they have no sea ice anymore
and so they're just doing whatever they
can do to survive.
Ooh,
that's creepy.
There's a really fucking scary video of
this.
A polar bear.
There's a seal on an ice shelf and the
polar bear slips up behind the seal and
the seal isn't.
No,
and the seals like,
oh Jesus.
They just tries to get away and he's got
really sad look on his face.
I've seen that video.
It's just like,
oh you Lucille,
and he gets into the water and then the
polar bears in the water right behind
them seconds later,
and then the polar bear comes out with
an incident in his jaws as a Goddamn
ruth was animal.
It's poppy's.
Got to eat,
was no other way.
There's no.
And it's enormous.
So there it is.
Look at it.
He just slowly creeps up.
It slowly,
just moving around.
And that sea lion.
Is that a sea lion?
Yeah,
that's a static seal.
So apparently they differentiate seals.
So like that one's a good tasting one
and then I think if it,
if this is the one that gets eaten,
it's the good tasting one.
And then there's another one that it's
really nasty with the sharp teeth.
So the polar bears and leave that one
alone,
like a leopard seal.
So when you mean,
yeah,
it's not that bad,
but it's a that some CEO that lives up
in the Arctic that's kind of bad ass
leopard seals are amazing.
Oh yeah.
That's a crazy animal.
I remember that marching at the penguins
movie.
I didn't even know there was a leopard
seal real.
He's like,
well,
we're just chilling.
Look at him.
And he just right in the water after
him.
Sorry Dude,
you ain't gonna make it there.
I like the silence is kind of epic.
There's a standup comedian,
Kevin Fitzgerald,
he's a,
uh,
also a veterinarian and I worked with
them once in Denver and he told me that
polar bears are one of the few animals
that when they come out of the womb to
elect a little alien from the movie
alien,
the burst out of the chest lifting to
bite you.
And he's like,
they are predatory from the moment they
come out of the vagina.
Yeah.
You said they just look at you
different.
They look at you like your meat leds.
Interesting.
So,
uh,
another friend of mine,
a woman named Rebecca who's really good
with animals,
she,
um,
she works with,
she's worked with all kinds of animals,
but she mostly focuses on raptors now.
But,
um,
she worked with cats back in the day and
she said that,
um,
mountain lions are big kitty cats.
They're giant house cats.
So if you can understand a house cat,
you can understand a mountain lion
leopards and jaguars very different
thing.
It's just like,
it's exactly what you were saying,
you know,
they're looking at you for you to make a
mistake and it's just a very different
vibe from those cats and funded and
mountain lions.
It's not that I remember that.
Yeah,
don't make.
it was interesting because it's,
you know,
back to our talk about Jaguars coming
back into the United States.
Well,
any animal that's forced to kill things
with its face in order to stay alive,
sketchy thing to have in your
neighborhood in San Francisco.
They're just so big.
They need so much food too.
I mean,
you think about how big a polar bears,
how much actual meat the thing must need
to consume in order to keep that mass a
lot.
I mean,
they,
uh,
I,
there's a place called Ollie's big game
lodge and packs in Nebraska and it's one
of these places in the middle of western
Nebraska is kind of a knower,
but it's where you get off the highway
if you've got to go eat and uh,
and you,
you walk in,
they're like,
holy shit,
there's this giant 12 foot tall polar
bear stuffed like right at the door when
you open up the door and it just,
it gives you an instantaneous notion of
how small you are compared to a polar
bear.
They're the biggest,
right?
Yeah.
They're bigger than a Kodiak bears.
Yep.
Wow.
Yeah.
That's a weird thing,
right?
An animal that lives whereas no
vegetation and does the law all the life
comes from the sea and it's bigger than
all of them.
See,
blubber must be good.
What isn't also that principle that the
larger mammals Bergman's rule,
the further north you go,
the larger body has to be in order to
maintain his skull Bergman's rule.
Thus Scandinavians.
Yeah.
That's another animal.
Bears are that Steve Rinella likes to
call charismatic megafauna.
That's an,
that's an old biological term for um,
for when back in the seventies when,
you know,
save the whales and everything and
everybody who was studying keystone
species like Krill or you know,
things that aren't very charismatic were
like,
man,
everybody wants to say the charismatic
megafauna and what really is the key to
everything of these,
this indiscriminate Krill or you know,
this little teeny forage fish or
whatever,
whatever.
Or like ants we were talking about.
They say of all the aunts died,
there would be no life on this planet
inside of 100 years.
Wow.
Dead.
Even though it might be less than 100
years.
Find out what would happen if all the
ants dot.
I think it's actually less than 100 fire
ants.
I hate fire ants with.
They're not nice.
They're definitely.
When I first discovered fire,
I knew they existed all the time,
but I'd never actually encountered them
until I was in Texas in Austin digging
wild onions and these ants crawl over my
hand.
Like,
oh look,
there's an isolated Florida Florida.
There were all over the place and my
friend Jesse is like,
people have died for sure.
There was some little old lady.
You remember the story?
She tripped,
fell right onto a mound and they just
consumed or with bites.
Wow.
And just fucked her up.
They thought she was a threat and time
to take you out.
God,
what's it going?
It was going to be on that poor ladies
soon.
I don't know.
Um,
you're aware of bullet ants,
right?
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
That's a,
that's an interesting one.
Didn't Steve and counter Bolivia and
Bolivia.
It's the same place where he ate a
monkey.
Yeah.
No,
thanks dude.
You wouldn't eat a monkey now.
That's where you cross the line.
But if someone cooked it in front of you
and it smelled good,
it was in the bowl and you were with
these people and they were all eating
at.
You wouldn't take a bite.
I don't know.
I'd have to judge that when I got there.
I think you would.
I would probably try and get out of that
situation before it ever happened.
I would worry about primate primate
diseases,
like I know they're cooking it really
well,
but I know that prions,
prions,
it caused mad cow disease that come from
brain matter.
Well,
you know,
chronic wasting.
Yeah.
Is that from prions as well?
Same thing.
Yeah.
And then chronic wasting disease for
folks who don't know what we're talking
about is a disease that affects dear and
it's really common in the Midwest and
they think that it may have originated,
at least this is the rumor from these
weird commercial dear farms where they
grow all these deer and they all lived
together because apparently one of the
things that happens is if deer eat out
of the same spot,
like that's where it develops.
Like if deer,
like if there's like a feed tray and
they're all eating out of the feature,
that's unnatural for the wild,
right?
Yeah.
It's uh,
it's,
you know,
it's one of those things that are
difficult to.
I mean,
I get asked about it all the time,
like,
well,
what do I do with,
you know,
if I want to make chops or for I want to
make stock out of the bones of the deer,
I shot,
what do I do with cwt?
And it's,
I've done an exhaustive look of all the
science that's out there and it's never
jumped the species barrier to humans to
humans.
It's,
um,
it's primarily gonna be located in,
in spinal tissue.
So your pelvis to skull and that's not
what we know.
So if it was me,
uh,
and there was testing available for my
dear,
I would absolutely do it.
And if you're in the clear and the
clearer and if not it was too hard.
I would probably keep the limb bones but
not the uh,
but not anything off the spinal column
because I've just,
you know,
and you would keep the limb bones for
marrow.
Uh,
yeah.
Either marrow or um,
or making a stocks and broths.
And then,
you know,
cooking,
cooking shanks on the bone.
Right?
And when you do shanks,
you braise them slow cook.
Um,
and that's a neglected part of,
uh,
a lot of undulates right?
I think it's a,
the part of the single easiest way of,
you know,
use the stupid catchphrase opening or a
game because it grinding shank meat
socks because there's so much connected
tissue and they're easy to solve for the
sawzall or hacksaw.
They usually will fit in your pot and
they're amazing race like that.
And even if they,
if that's all you do different and
besides your butcher will like you
because all he's got to do is solve them
off,
put them in a butcher paper,
butcher paper and bring it back to you.
Now you started your,
your hunting and cooking career off you
start as a chef and then you wanted to
get closer and may maybe understand what
you were cooking better.
Is that a good way to describe it?
Is that accurate as sort of.
I mean,
I,
uh,
I started hunting in Minnesota and my
best friend was the
outdoor writer for the St Paul Pioneer
Press and we had been fishing at the
time and then hunting season came around
and he invited me out.
And it hit,
well let me preface this,
but he'd been sort of plying me with
mallards and with rabbits and with some
venison prior to me ever going out so
that he had killed.
He wanted you to try and this and you
were already a shaft by then.
Well,
at that point it was a newspaper
reporter.
So I started as a restaurant Cook,
you know,
line cook and a low level sous chef.
Then I went into newspapers and um,
that was still in as a newspaper
reporter at that point.
And I,
I got into it because I wanted to eat
these things.
I loved cooking the mallards I love
cooking pheasants.
I love cooking,
you know,
medicine and he can't buy it.
So gotta learn to get it.
And the other thing that was really life
changing about it was.
So I'm a pretty good fisherman and when
I'm in a place for awhile,
uh,
you learn to read the body water,
you know,
in my case back in Long Island,
you learn tides,
you learn weather patterns,
you learned all of the little
intricacies of what it takes to actually
get on fish.
So most anglers are just and lines,
the real fisherman knows where to put
the boat to find the fish,
knows how fast patrol knows what,
what angle to the waves you want to be
in,
all these little detailed things.
And I knew that,
uh,
my friend Chris knew this by looking at
the land,
like he could just take out a glance,
you could look at a field like,
nope,
no fences,
we're going to be in that and I didn't
have,
how do you know?
And he just knew because he'd done this
a zillion times and his ability to read
land,
like I could read water.
I wanted that ability and that every bit
as much as I'm the eating part of it was
what brought me into it.
Now when you say that you really enjoyed
cooking them and you really enjoy eating
them,
is it because the flavors are different?
They're more complex,
they're more like,
you know,
one of the main criticisms that people
have said to me when I talk about wild
game,
like,
ah,
I tried Venessa in like it's game me and
my God damn somebody ruined you because
it's just,
it's not like they did something wrong
with it.
I mean there's two things to me.
So one I think we both agree that what
we would call Gamie is somebody screwed
up,
right?
So poor you almost 75 percent of all
good venison care happens before the
meet ever gets the kitchen.
So that can give you what we would call
Gamey.
But I mean I've had people eat backstrap
that it was perfectly prepared,
perfectly cared for.
And they said,
well,
it's kind of gave me what they're
talking about is that it doesn't taste
like corn.
Every meat animal,
including to some extent salmon that we
will get an a supermarket is corn fed.
They,
they corn feed salmon.
Yeah.
That it's in the pellets that they feed
them Christ.
Yeah.
Goddamn corn industry that it has its
tentacles deep into America.
Right.
And you know,
those corn tastes like it has very
particular favorite pillow file.
And so with,
with that flavor profile is broken by
deer that ate something else.
People are like,
ah,
it's different.
Well,
yeah,
it tastes like something.
Someone can actually lived a life.
Tell me that about mule deer,
that they don't like mule deer because
mule deer tastes like the sage that it
eats and that they like white tails
because they corn.
I'm like,
Jesus Christ man.
Like I've had a mule deer.
They taste great.
You're out of your mind.
It's a no.
Then people will say,
elk is so much better than deer.
I'm like,
okay,
I get it.
I mean there's some minor differences in
subtle differences
if you put one next to each other.
Yeah,
there's a little bit of a difference,
but it's not that dramatic.
Like I'm a duck hunter.
The difference between a Spoonie and a
pin tail is profound.
What's a spoonie and what's a pin tail?
So a spoonie is in northern shoveler and
it's one of the least desired ducks that
we are then shoveler.
Yeah.
And is it a,
a diver doc?
Is that what it is?
It's kind of a hybrid.
Um,
it's,
it's technically a puddle duck,
but it dives more so than the other
puddle duck if you don't mind explaining
to people what the differences are.
So every bucket you've seen in a park
with his butt up in the air,
that's a Dabbler or a puddle duck.
So a diver duck is a duck that dives
very deep and the deepest of all,
or a third kind of duck called the sea
dock,
which as you might guess,
listen deep,
deep,
deep water.
So divers,
we'd be like bluebills,
canvasbacks,
redheads,
buffalo heads,
gold,
Nih.
Um,
and then puddle docs would be obviously
the Mallard,
which everybody knows.
Mallards pin tales,
spoonie wigeon a teal.
And so in general,
puddle ducks tastes better than diver
ducks because the,
what they eat and,
and so,
but,
but ducks are all omnivores much like
pigs and bears.
So you have a spoonie which loves to eat
shrimp.
He things and algae may versus a pentel
which loves seeds in seeds of all time,
all kinds.
And that's a more tasty bird.
Any bird that eats seeds as a matter of
habit,
human beings are going to like to eat it
more because it's just a creates a set
of flavors that we're more familiar
with.
Now,
the exception is that are kind of
fascinating.
If you talked to newfoundlanders where
Icelanders or anyway,
uh,
the people who are grown up eating
seabirds,
they love that fishy,
low tidy flavor thing going on at the
same.
I see her.
You're getting hairy.
Eyebrow.
I want to try even though I know I'll
hate it.
I want to try that fermented shark that
they live in Iceland.
No,
you don't have.
You had it.
Tell me what it's like.
MMM.
What's not toe.
It's fermented stinky soybeans.
So I've heard of that stuff too.
It's disgusting.
Supposedly stinky blue,
cheesy,
fishy ammoniated.
It attacks your mouth.
Ammoniated.
Yeah.
Heavily ammoniate.
Now the Iceland people with a drunk when
they eat this.
I think it's just was there was nothing.
It's like a polar bear.
There's nothing else.
So he developed a taste for a while.
Apparently you can't eat that.
That shark fresh what?
Yeah,
I think.
I think it's another vitamin A or
something like that.
There's some reason you can't eat that.
It's a greenland shark and you can't eat
a greenland shark fresh.
So it was the only way to eat.
It was too.
For a minute.
How bizarre.
Yeah,
and so they became the first guy to
figure that one out.
Yeah,
right.
Let's eat the rotten one.
How to prepare it.
You have to figure out how to ferment
that thing because I have never seen or
heard of seen videos of people trying
it.
I've never heard anybody's tried it.
They enjoyed it.
Anybody who lives in Iceland though will
tell you like it's a.
it's a delicacy.
We like it.
Like I don't understand.
I wonder what our delicacy is.
What is the thing that we either in
California or in the United States
really,
really like that.
Everybody else in the world was like,
holy crap,
how can you eat that?
That's a good question.
I don't think we have anything like
that.
Our food is so bland.
Like an American food is like,
you think of a cheeseburger and fries or
steak and mashed potatoes.
You don't think of anything that has
like an incredibly potent flavors to it.
Yeah,
I mean,
I can think of some regionalities like
scrapple.
Right,
but,
but that's not you.
You call scrapple regional American,
but not dominant American food.
What's scrapple again?
Eh,
that's basically Lipson assholes.
Ground up really small and mixed with
either cornmeal or,
or sometimes oatmeal and it still won't
be potent.
It's baked it in,
is it?
Yeah.
Liver Mush is even more potent.
Liver,
much liver mush,
Mush.
Really?
It's basically that,
but it's made with liver and they're
both breakfast meats and you know,
I've had good scrapple.
I've not had liver much that I really,
really enjoyed it.
It's kind of a uh,
uh,
you see a lot in south central
Pennsylvania,
West Virginia,
Tennessee,
that area well lit.
Well that's.
Wow.
See,
that's grapple.
Yeah.
So it's like you cut it like a low flow
meatloaf.
Yep.
And then you fry it.
Oh Wow.
So you horrible.
Do you boil it?
How do you get into that state?
Oh,
it's all liquid.
It's all liquid liquid.
It's basically like scrapple is the
scraps from the,
from slaughtering a pig.
So is it almost like a gelatin thing,
like a head cheese type of a scenario?
It is,
but I kind of,
I would say is probably a more wholesome
product.
Head cheese is very strange.
I didn't know what head Cheese Romano
should do tat until probably like five
years ago.
And uh,
I remember watching a video of someone
making head.
She had cheese.
I've never had it.
It's okay.
So here's the thing.
All it is,
is while the German way that is really
dig on the gelatin and I'm not super
heavy on the,
that gelatin comes from the collagen
breaks down and the tissues,
those
take a pig's head.
Okay.
And typically you will either have the
ears thrown in there or you'll have an
extra foot thrown in there for some more
collagen.
You boil it slowly with a lot of spices
and herbs until practically falls apart.
Then you fish everything out.
And then the iron rule of,
of head cheese making is,
if it looks like meat,
keep it fairly big.
If you have no idea what it is,
chop it very small and then,
and then you pack it into a loaf pan or
a sausage casing and then you boil down
the cooking liquid by half and then that
really concentrates the gelatin and then
you pour that hot broth over the mixture
that you packed into the,
the loaf pan or the or the sausage
casing or whatever,
and then you put it in the refrigerator
and it sets and you eat it cold.
So the best head cheese as is where the
gelatin is set just enough where it kind
of melts when it hits the heat of your
mouth.
And so it's not 99 new sort of to a knox
gelatin and like,
um,
and it's,
it's actually very,
very good.
And it's a,
it needs pickles and slash or mustard
pickles and slash or.
Yeah,
there's head cheese,
so yeah,
it looks good.
That looks better than scrapple.
Oh yeah.
It's much better than scrapple,
but it's weird distinction.
I mean,
I guess it's because it's not Dixon
assholes.
More uteruses please.
I mean,
I've always been fascinated by sharp
prudery.
Just the idea that people figured out a
long time ago how to draw things and
preserved thing.
That's it.
Had cheese.
Okay.
That's my.
That's how I make it.
That's called Beta tested.
That's an Italian style.
Okay.
And then you slice it very thin.
See that arc thing and the bottom left
hand corner.
That's a little bit slice of pig ear.
Oh Wow.
Really?
And that's edible.
You can now yet.
Well,
it's been boiled for hours and hours.
Just become superintendent because I
think of them as things.
I feed my dogs.
Those are the pet store if they're not
boiled.
Yeah,
yeah.
Pigs are a weird one,
man.
That's such a weird thing because you
find out how smart they are and like
commercial pig farming becomes very
disturbing.
I find out how.
That's another reason why I got into
hunting so too.
I have not bought meat or fish for the
house since [inaudible].
That's awesome.
With maybe a handful of exceptions.
I bought a chicken a couple of times,
but part of that is I.
I would prefer to opt out of that system
because you're exactly right.
Yeah.
I just did a podcast recently with my
friend Ari,
Ari Shaffir,
who's a stand up comedian and his,
his podcast is called the skeptic tank
and we went into that because he's never
a hunted and he asked me about it and
that is what I gave him is pretty much
my reason for doing it in the first
place.
I felt like I didn't want to be a part
of that system anymore and I wasn't sure
if I wanted to be a vegetarian.
I was like,
it's going to be one of these things,
either vegetarian or a hunter,
so let me try this hunting thing.
And then I got into it.
But it's the connection with the food.
It becomes.
It becomes a completely different
experience and it's so hard to explain
that without sounding pretentious or
without just repeating myself over and
over again,
which I've done many,
many,
many times on this podcast.
But when you,
if I'll,
I'll pull like an elk backstrap out of
the freezer tonight and I'll thought out
and I'll,
you know,
marinade,
put some kosher salt and pepper and
grill it.
And it's a wonderful experience.
Like while I'm cooking this thing,
I'm all excited.
I remember the hunt,
I remember,
you know,
seeing the elk,
the whole thing.
I mean,
it's just,
it's a totally to.
And when you're eating it,
it's just rich with vitamins and flavor
and it's alive.
I mean,
it's definitely not alive,
but I mean,
it has this taste to it.
It's just so different than anything
you're going to buy in a store.
Well,
for me as a cook,
having entered this whole game as a,
as a cook or you know,
this pursuit of hunting,
um,
it really challenges me to make great
food out of every bet because,
you know,
you broke it,
you bought it.
And tacos to language made from elk
tongue,
phenomenal.
Um,
head cheese made from a dose head,
a brace.
Shanks a hell I even,
I even made a venison tripe.
One of the most delicious meals that I
ever cooked with wild game was on our
first hunt Rinella.
I'm cooked a deer head in the ground.
Oh yeah.
Sky,
like,
uh,
he,
he read about it in that book,
Big Sky,
the Guthrie Book.
And he decided that he wanted to try it
that way.
So this is like the first time you ever
tried it.
And we buried this thing.
We put hot coals,
you wrapped it up in a cloth and a wet
cloth,
put it under ground,
poured hot coals all over.
And I do not remember,
but it was amazing.
Whatever he did,
he did it right.
And maybe he didn't solve it.
I don't remember.
I love Steve will always take the hard
way out.
Oh,
he's the hardest motherfucker on earth.
Every time I out with him I feel like a
pussy.
He just always wanted to do everything
hard and if he doesn't get miserable.
Like I watched a show once where he saw
this giant bull elk on the first day.
It was hunt within the first couple of
hours and he didn't shoot it because he
didn't want to be done hunting.
When that's why you go fishing
afterwards.
I'm like,
you're out of your fucking time to go
fishing.
He explained it to me afterwards.
It made more sense and it was because he
had just come from Kentucky where he had
did another show and he had shot an elk
and Kentucky like literally the week
before,
so he felt bad about shooting one right
away.
I'm like,
it's not like you're going to let it go
to waste.
Right?
And he's like,
well,
we have to make a show and I can just
shoot it on the first day of shoot on
the first day and then pretend you're
looking for an l three days afterwards.
Jesus Christ,
I,
you know about editing your hot tea
because he's so.
He has.
So his ethics are so strong and his
inability to be disingenuous is so
powerful that he won't do that.
Well,
the one I did with him was like,
Hey,
I'm,
I'm older than he is.
I'm like,
I'd like to climb to the top of this
mountain and look for things and then
sit here for,
until
I find something and then walk to that
thing and shoot it.
He's like,
let's climb all over these mountains
like woo.
And I'm like,
Oh dude,
I'm just going to sit here and like,
this is where we saw deer.
I'm going to know as it turned out,
he was right.
He knows what he's doing.
I want an a mule deer hunt with them
recently and you know,
I was like,
let's go after them now.
He's like,
no,
no.
Just sit and wait.
You don't want to blow them out.
I'm like,
you sure just go,
let's go.
He's like,
you can go if you want them.
Okay,
go down the hill.
They're gone.
If I could take off.
He's like,
well,
go after him tomorrow.
I'm like,
tomorrow,
like,
but it's like one of those things,
what you friend could read the land.
Like you have to listen.
Like when you,
when you have someone that has this deep
experience in something that's very odd
information,
like where the quail will be.
I gotTa,
you know,
Dude,
I've been doing this.
I had that with ducks.
I can do that with ducks and geese.
Is that your favorite bird?
It's,
well,
I don't have my favorite favorite book.
Maybe grouse,
grouse,
maybe never had it.
Uh,
what's it like?
Imagine it's what a chicken dreams about
being when it grows up and goes wild.
It's a wild chicken.
It's a little tiny wild chicken.
They're not that tiny.
What's a fat grouse?
I shot a big blue grouse in Utah that
plucked gutted and dress just it looked
Jessica chicken you buy in the store was
two pounds.
Woo.
That was pretty heavy.
That's about as big as they get.
That's like about like that.
That's a pretty big animal.
No kidding.
And Sage grouse or even bigger?
A really.
What's like the biggest world record
grouse,
like a five pound grouse Capercaillie in
Sweden there I think there were like 15
pounds or so.
Oh,
it's a fucking Turkey.
Pretty much.
They don't have turkeys there.
So.
Wow.
So I mean I guess the biggest gallon
[inaudible] bird would be the Turkey I
was interested in.
Um,
what the difference between wild Turkey
and regular Turkey is.
And it's surprisingly not as big as you
might think.
The breast was almost identical except
it's very narrow,
but the wings and the other brother,
the drumsticks did have a different
flavor to them.
Yeah,
it was more just more distinct and they
worked for living.
Yes,
they're out there hustling.
Yeah.
Which is the same.
You could say about pigs,
like the darkness of the meat of wild
pig is so preferable to a domestic pigs.
I love,
I loved shooting wild hogs.
Well you have to,
first of all,
that's one of those things.
That's one of the animals that really,
when you talk to people that are anti
hunting and anti,
they just want to let nature run its
course.
Like there's some animals where you
literally can't do that,
like pigs or one of them.
Especially invasive pigs.
I had no so 500 pigs in California for
years and years and years.
So,
and I've heard all these stories about
Texas and a few years ago I finally went
down to South East Texas to do.
I do punting and cooking schools.
And um,
so the guy,
I was working with this in Bay city and
so we're down there and uh,
he's like,
okay,
first thing you have to understand is
that these are a problem.
Like when we were talking about.
So we went out and there are these herds
of pigs and like 90 pigs in a shot,
the walk into a field to do $100,000
damage in one night and it's,
it's astonishing and this is all year
round and I had no idea like,
because you know,
if you found it pigs in California,
it's a hunt.
If you go to Texas,
it's like how many can you kill and you
still won't make a dent on the
population as a story that I've told
before.
But I'll tell it again just for the sake
of this conversation.
There's a new highway they opened up in
Texas and the first night they opened up
the road.
Forty car accidents with pigs.
Lao just overrun.
They were just overrun with big.
Yeah.
Car accidents and wild game and
population control is one of the most
surprising statistics when you give them
to tell people $2,
million car accidents with deer every
year and the one point $5 million at
least in the United States with,
with deer.
And they will what?
Like people don't know.
Go what?
Oh,
you're one and a half million car
accidents with deer a year.
Just the United States and they're
delicious.
Yeah.
Years ago I did.
I was working at the pipe press pioneer
press and St Paul and I did a data
analysis,
one of the first ones that was ever done
and try dear vehicle collisions and
apparently if you're in an oca county,
north of the twin cities on November
eighth at dusk,
watch your ass.
That's the one day that was like,
so you'd like.
There's a huge cluster right there.
Well,
the November is the Rut.
Yeah,
November.
That's when they just get completely
bonkers.
You're running into traffic and.
Well,
you've been to a singles bar at closing
time.
Yes.
Well,
I've also been an Iowa in the Rut.
Was just there a few weeks ago.
You got to Iowa Tag.
Yes.
I got a governor's tag for my buddy of
mine.
Owns some property out there and knows
people.
You're lucky.
Yes.
Very lucky.
Yeah,
you could get one there.
It takes a couple of years.
He put it in points.
You can get one every five years.
But um,
I was amazing,
like the,
the white tail population is so strong
and one of the reasons is they don't
have a rifle season.
Right?
It's on only shotgun and archery.
So you gotta work for it because if
you're going to shoot some of the
shotgun,
you got to be pretty fucking close.
I'd rather use a bow even with,
uh,
with uh,
say bit rifle,
barrel slug.
You still talking a hundred yards.
Is that the most you could shoot?
Went out.
I've heard guys shoot farther but
weekend and week out 100 yards with
those rifled save at slugs.
And I would imagine there's a giant drop
to how far it falls in 100 yards.
Yeah,
you gotta be aware of it.
It's like she didn't have top of the
back about a hundred yards.
I showed it to 70 and I lose two inches
at 300.
And I've heard this with some places,
some states that allow you to use
shotguns,
but you can't use a scope.
Oh,
that's interesting.
Yeah.
You can't use the scope on the shotgun.
You have to use the old,
the old timey iron sights or you could
probably use a peep site.
Do you have a favorite game that you
enjoy cooking?
Is there anything that you like this is
my favorite
game to cook in a variety of different
ways?
Or do you just like all of them?
Well,
I think if you're talking about a
variety of different ways,
ducks and venison,
um,
but if you're talking about favorite
thing to cook it in general,
go back to grouse.
But graphs are not as versatile but I
love the flavor of grouse,
but it's,
you know,
it's a whole bird you're cooking.
And is it just,
is it because of its wild diet?
It just has a more complex flavor to it.
Is it?
Very much so it's,
it's,
there's nothing that tastes like a
grouse.
The,
it's sort of like a chicken,
but you'll know you're eating grass now.
Well,
I didn't know this either until fairly
recently that the,
as you were explaining before,
that there's different kinds of ducks
and the ducks and the seeds are
preferable,
but diver ducks you can eat,
but they have like,
do you,
do you enjoy them?
Oh yeah.
And they have like a fishy taste or
because they primarily seafood.
So,
uh,
this is a great example of Diet.
So brant,
which is like a sea goose,
um,
there's east coast brand and west coast
brand and the season just ended
yesterday I think on Brandon and they,
um,
and so on the west coast,
they are the best eating waterfowl.
There is period Barton because they eat
eel grass in there have a very clean,
almost celine flavor.
It's very fishy.
It's not Pondi,
it's just,
it's,
it's a fantastic birds.
You shoot it,
the brand and the east coast in the East
Sea lettuce a see a seaweed revolting,
like barely edible.
Really,
like barely just got to chew through it.
Yeah.
But you know,
so canvas backs.
Are there a diver?
Red Heads?
They're a diver.
Uh,
for the most part I'll always pluck them
because they have a different diet and,
but on the other hand,
Goldeneye as buffalo heads most blue
bills but not all ring next.
A lot of those birds,
you know,
there's still tastes good,
but I'll,
I'll tend to skin them.
It is really fascinating to me that the
taste of when you eat an animal depends
so much on what the animal's diet is and
then it makes me think about my own diet
and like what is going on with the cells
of my own body.
And you think about people that are on
poor diets that have terrible food that
they consume and they choose to drink
soda all the time and they,
their tissue itself is affected.
So drastic lung pig,
this one sweet.
Oh,
long pig animals called human.
I don't know what that accident was,
but I don't like it.
Have you ever had blueberry bear?
Um,
I've had Manzanita bear.
What's that?
So Anthony,
is it just a different bearer?
A,
just a different barrier that bears
loved to eat in northern California.
Oh,
okay.
And how was it similar to like the
blueberry bear concept?
Well,
they didn't turn anything blue,
but uh,
but it was a,
it was amazing.
I mean it was super sweet,
super fatty.
Just very mild.
Yeah,
that's what I hear that blueberry bear
is like the ultimate game.
I think you get a bear in the fall
that's been eating blueberries and like
Rinella did a whole episode.
It on his show where he
cut one open and it had purple fat.
Crazy.
Amazing.
There's actually a better one.
And it lives right near you.
So legend has it.
So I believe the state record,
black bear and California as a 700
pounder from the San Gabriel mountains
in Ventura.
Trust.
So.
Or it's been from Ventura County.
From Ventura.
Yes.
700 prejudice on far.
So apparently these bears live in the
mountains and they come down to the
avocado groves and gorge themselves on
Avocados.
And it's been,
it's one of my bucket list goals is to
get what they call a guacamole bear.
A guacamole because that's supposed to
be really good.
Only imagine how delicious a avocado
eating bear would taste.
I wonder if it would affect it that much
because Avocados are a fairly mild
fruit,
but as a fruit.
Right,
but when you consider all the kind of
fruit,
but the fact quality would be amazing.
Yeah.
It was very rich and fat.
Right.
I eat a lot of Avocados.
I wonder if I would see.
The thing about the blueberry bear
though is that it's got that engaging
sort of sweetness to it that I think
would be really interesting.
I don't think you'd get that from the
avocado.
Now you have an urge to eat Mexican
food,
I think.
Is that what?
Is this,
the other Rinella One?
Yeah.
It's just showing how many cuts into it.
This fat has this insane sort of Blueish
hint to it,
Huh?
Yeah.
He can see how that.
Is this when he gets himself?
No,
that was later.
That was the.
Yeah.
Well,
it's just,
he's just crazy.
He's still.
The best part is that everything is
fucking guy.
He said trick gnosis.
He's had lyme disease.
Get charged for the ups.
Yeah.
Oh,
he got Giardia.
Giardia.
Yeah.
If you.
Um,
the other cool thing is that if you were
to get one of these guacamole bears,
you can freeze it and be free of chicken
houses because south of about Oregon
draw a line all the way across the
country.
The bears there,
if they have it,
will tend to have a,
a variety called trick and trick and
Ellis by Rallis,
which you can kill by freezing.
Interesting.
So,
but north of there from the northern
tier of this country and all Canada and
Alaska,
it's called trick and I nativa and that
one is resistant to freezing so it stays
alive even if you have it in the freezer
for months.
Right.
That's sick.
Creepy animal.
I know.
Well,
I mean it's from up there.
So it must be,
you know,
frost,
frost resistant.
I was surprised how good beer taste I
was too.
Yeah.
That's one of those ones where you go,
I don't know if I want to eat this.
This is just a teddy bear.
St Says Yogi.
This is all the amp for more physicians
of ours.
Madec megafauna.
That's the weird.
I've never had people more mad at me for
anything.
I've ever shot than bear,
like they don't.
People don't seem to be that mad about a
deer.
Some people are,
but most people understand it like you
ate that you're going to eat it.
That's the way shot.
And we are who we are because we hunt
deer know,
anthropologically speaking.
I mean there's all kinds of evidence to
show that the reason why we can run,
we were the only primate with an arch.
The reason
that we can actually throw properly,
the reason why that we can communicate
so complicated in so many complicated
ways.
There's all kinds of reasons that the
structure of our shoulders,
the structure of our hips that are a
great amount of the way we're built in
the way we think and the way we act has
to do with us teaming up to hunt large
deer.
Like things real [inaudible].
Where'd you get this?
All over the,
um,
the anthropological literature.
I mean,
I could cite you a bunch of books,
but um,
but there's,
I mean,
obviously it's debatable,
but the consensus is that there's an
enormous amount of,
uh,
of developments that stemmed out of
pursuit hunting.
And ganging up on things like mammoths
and rhinos and large,
basically large,
large herbivores.
And,
you know,
that's why we were hardwired hunt deer.
Well,
one of the things that I said that I was
describing to my friend Ari about it as
there's this strange familiarity.
Yep.
Uh,
and almost like this,
a deep reward system that gets plugged
into that you weren't even aware that
you had when the deer's down and you
know,
when you're quartering it and cutting it
up,
it's like,
oh,
I kind of know how to do this,
or at least I don't know how to do this,
but this seems normal to me.
It seems familiar.
I mean,
we've been in.
This is the other thing about some of
the research I've been doing lately is
that everybody hunts deer or something
like a deer.
So all over the world.
So my banker guy named Omar,
uh,
I was doing some banking stuff and I was
talking to him about the book I just
wrote.
And he said,
Oh yeah,
you know,
I really miss hunting gazelles and the
eastern deserts of Lebanon.
Oh,
right.
I,
it's the same reaction as you know,
I have a friend from the Yucatan who
hunts deer in the Yucatan and you know,
I've uh,
uh,
another friend from Hokkaido in the
Northern Ireland in Japan who,
who hunts the same sick of blacktail in
Alaska now that he used to hunt in
Hokkaido as a kid and you know,
South Africans and New Zealanders and
men,
even if you can be for,
if you're smart and thinking out there,
you're going to say,
well,
what about Australia and Australia?
I mean,
if,
I don't know if you've ever eaten
kangaroo,
but kangaroo looks exactly like medicine
and pretty much tastes like medicine.
Yeah,
it's a crazy deer,
right?
It's kind of strange.
Sort of a weird hopping deer with a tail
ish.
Yeah.
Uh,
so let me,
there's.
So the,
the human connection with hunting and
eating something like a deer is very,
very,
is worldwide and in very,
very deep.
Now this new book that you have here,
I've been reading it,
I was reading it today actually,
buck,
Buck Moose.
That's a lot of really interesting
information about animals and about how
to prepare them.
The difference.
One of the things that I thought it was
really funny,
it was the whole point about
testosterone.
Testosterone stinks.
And like the animals that everybody
wants the big bucks with the big racks,
they're going to be smelly animals.
They're going to be tougher if you get
them before the Rut,
which is not easy,
but if you get them before the route,
they're perfectly fine.
But that's the rub is that,
that's when they're easiest to get,
when they're all horny and confused.
Yep.
Um,
but you've got some great fucking
recipes and ideas in here,
man.
How,
how long did it take you to put this
together over?
I've started a,
I don't know,
maybe some of it 10 years,
but,
but actually sitting there writing it
two years.
Um,
you know,
because all the recipes,
I had a test and I had to send the
recipes out to,
uh,
you know,
lots of readers because one of the
things is important for me is that my
recipes are as water tight as possible.
So I send them out to civilians.
I don't let other chefs test my recipes
because I,
first of all,
they're not gonna follow the recipe.
Second of all,
they wouldn't.
They would have their own bullshit.
Oh yeah.
Because it's just you.
They can't help themselves.
So no kidding.
It just is.
It's,
I'm happy I'm at peace with it.
But uh,
but I.
What I want is for somebody who reads
what I write to be able to make what I
made.
So anybody who's ever sent a text
message knows that if you ever send a
text message,
what you write is not necessarily what
the person hears in their head.
Right?
So at that can't,
that can't go if I'm writing a recipe,
because especially because,
think about it,
right?
If I'm going to tell you to do x,
y,
or z with the tenderloin,
there's only one.
You only get one shot at it.
There's only one set of tenderloins on
any animal.
And if I'm going to tell you to do
something with it,
that's beyond whatever it is that you
normally do.
If better damn work.
Because you don't,
you can't get,
just go to the store to get another 10
line,
right?
Like you can get another chicken,
you can't get another,
the tenderloin,
so you may tenderloin from a moose or
from a prior.
And so everything has to be airtight and
in and tested.
Will any of these recipes work with
domestic animals?
Like if somebody is really curious about
it?
Sure.
Uh,
how would you know how to substitute?
I would say a bison or grassfed beef
will get you pretty close and flavor and
a lamb or goat will get you pretty close
in size.
No lamb doesn't taste like medicine,
but in terms of size,
like a shank recipe for example,
or a shoulder recipe or a neck recipe.
Land would be a perfect substitute.
But if you want to get close to what a
good deer or an elk tastes like,
grass fed beef or bison.
And when people do buy commercially
available,
venison and elk,
doesn't it all come from other countries
as a come from New Zealand?
Most of it,
at least most of them,
most of whatever it is that you will see
that called Venison will be red stag
from New Zealand,
but there are elk farms in the United
States that I've seen how commercially
for sale,
really Marshall Elk growing in the
United States.
That seems wrong.
You might say that,
but I couldn't possibly comment.
Does that seem a little.
But that's one of the weird things about
wild game is that you can't sell it.
Right?
I mean that's one of the really
appealing things about because they
belonged to all of us.
Yeah.
What's.
Well,
it's also the market hunting is what
wiped them out at the turn of the
century and the,
you know,
even as late as the 19 fifties,
it was a news item for somebody to get
an eight point.
Wow.
I know guys who an eight point buck what
he's talking about the yellers because
there there were almost wiped out.
Yeah.
I mean it was a news event even in the
sixties in some places.
So it's like these are the good old days
of deer hunting.
Yeah.
Well,
when I was in Iowa,
we saw a lot of,
we didn't see any big deer that got
close,
but we saw like,
wow,
like,
this is crazy.
There's,
they're here.
The biggest white tell ever saw was this
giant in western Kansas when I was quail
hunting as this is supposed to be Mecca.
Right.
It's a mecca.
I mean,
Kansas,
Iowa,
you know,
in Kansas for big,
giant white tails.
Yeah,
I know people that moved there.
My friend John Dudley moved there just
because just because of the deer
hunting,
he's an archer and there's a little
obsessive,
little crazy,
a little crazy.
Um,
do you have a,
a favorite?
Me.
I'm a mammal that you like to cook.
Eno.
Okay.
But the first thing that popped in my
head and was heavily ina have Alina,
and I think it's because I'm a fan of
the underdog a.
So I shot a couple of skunk pigs.
I'm so heavily in columns,
gunk,
pig.
It's not really a pig,
right?
Well,
it's,
it isn't,
but it isn't.
It's a peccary.
Um,
and it's native to the United States
where pigs are not.
And they look like pigs,
they act like pigs,
they are related to pigs on the family
tree,
but they're not,
they're not that close and there is no
reason why people should hate heavily
now.
So like if you go to Arizona or New
Mexico,
everybody loves how heavily,
like he was to eat and he'd go only to
South Texas.
There you go,
creepy fucker.
If you go to south Texas,
they're like,
ah,
they're disgusting over the rats or
whatever.
And so I was in south Texas and I said
to the landowner,
I was weighing like,
let me,
let me show you a couple of like a.
So I cleaned up because I was,
I was wondering about this mysterious
thing,
clan that you're not supposed to break
up,
which is the smaller back.
It's like,
you know,
it's kind of like a heavily in a tramp
stamp.
And,
and so if you,
if you skin the animal,
like you would scan a pig,
you never see it.
It's in the skin.
So if you come underneath the skin
you'll never nick it,
you'll have no problem.
And it's just like a little teeny pig.
And they taste fantastic.
They're really.
There is no off taste to them at all.
Describe it.
Was it pork pig like big,
like,
no.
More like pork pork.
Then wild boar is really.
Yeah,
they're there because they're almost,
I don't know if they're obligate
vegetarians,
but they're primarily vegetarians.
I know my friend Doug Stan Hope told me
that one killed his neighbor's dog.
Fucking they surrounded the dog and mold
it.
Well that's good.
Have you ever seen heavily to teeth?
Yeah,
the big ass crazy spikes.
They actually like spikes were,
were uh,
were wild boars have like a arcs like
comes.
They will.
They hunted this thing like the,
they killed it on purpose.
Look,
you're that fucking creepy bastard.
Jesus Christ.
Roar.
Ferocious looking weird.
Hobbit,
animal hobbit tag.
That doesn't want a real animal.
Right?
It looks like something from a movie
like Lord
of the rings movie.
But you know,
that said,
um,
I just,
I like it.
I,
I love cooking them because they're fun
and I like pork.
And you prepare it the same way you
would cook or the pork loin or.
I tend to go a lot of Mexican Central
American recipes because that's where
they live and in desert southwest kind
of stuff.
But you know,
took.
Get me wrong.
I love Angela.
Probably pronghorn antelope wouldn't be
my second.
I've heard this delicious save.
You'll hear it's delicious in your hair.
It's disgusting.
And here's why.
Because pronghorns are,
they're super nervous animals that are
like high strong,
dear basically,
even though they're out of here,
I'm pseudo capra something or other.
That's their,
that's their genus.
They're their own thing.
Weird side note there so fast because
they were evolved to run away from the
Cheetah,
this blue mind.
So the Cheetah in Africa was actually a
Cheetah and the American Great Plains
before the ice age,
it migrated back over the land bridge.
It got itself into Asia and Africa.
So the Cheetah that exists now is our
Cheetah,
said our cheetah died out in the ice
age.
In the end,
the pronghorn antelope did not.
So the antelope is essentially waiting
for the Cheetah.
Nothing can catch it.
The other so fast.
People call them speed.
Goats,
goats.
Yeah.
And so they're super nervous and they
die really easy.
Usually it's like,
wow,
I'm dead.
And they fall over.
And uh,
and so you go with what you do is you go
up,
you take your little shot,
Yay.
And then got him right there,
throw the wobbly bits in a bag and throw
it a cooler and get them out of the skin
as fast as possible.
If you do those two things,
it's some of the best events and you'll
see why do you have to get it out of the
skin as fast ball?
Because they burn hot body temperature
is hotter than a deer in there.
Hide holds heat better than a deer.
So those two things,
plus the fact that they're super nervous
like this,
they can go off in a hurry.
So what you see a lot of guys do is
let's say you and me and steve were
hunting antelope and you know,
I shot mine first thing in the morning
and you shot yours,
meaning an hour or two later.
But Steve can't buy a shot,
which is probably not how it would work.
But for the sake of the story,
so let's say steve finally gets one at
like 3:00
in the afternoon.
Yay.
Then we would start getting them.
That's,
you see that happen a lot and our,
our analysts will be ruined.
His will be fine.
Oh,
let's see.
So you just got to jump on it right away
and get it to a cooler as quickly as
possible.
You often hunt antelope and warm weather
to very hot,
right?
Like New Mexico in the summer,
late August,
September.
So it's like many things we were talking
about gaming ness.
It's just a preparation and an
understanding of what,
what you are required to do in order to
make sure that this meat is edible.
Exactly.
In tastes good.
Um,
there's,
there's a bunch of animals that people.
You've got to get out of here soon.
Soon.
We'll wrap this up.
We can wrap this up there.
There's a bunch of animals that,
uh,
I think,
have no equivalent in domestic food,
right?
Like what would you say if you've
wanted,
if you were trying to coach someone into
a trying wild game or being interested
in wild game,
what do you think would be one that you
would start them off with?
Something that's familiar.
So duck.
I'm venison backstrap.
Anything with wild boar because it's
basically if you had to pick a,
an a recipe out of this.
Oh,
this one I would do just a simple seared
backstrap with like a cumberland sauce
or a or steak.
Diane steak.
Diane.
Diane is a,
it's a 150 year old recipe.
That's a classic for a reason.
It's,
it's back.
It's Diane is for Diana,
the goddess of the hunt.
So originally in France it was a,
it was venison for recipe and it became
a beef recipe later and it is a recipe
with cognac or brandy,
a little bit of mustard,
a little bit of cream.
The drippings from the pants that.
Yup.
Good Lord.
That looks good.
And uh,
and at that actually my recipe,
I did that.
I did that on simply recipes.
Oh Nice.
And so it's a,
it's a million years old.
And it is amazing.
There's not,
I don't think I've ever encountered
anybody who has made my recipe for it
who didn't like it.
Goddammit.
I want to cook that tonight.
It's easy too.
That's the other thing.
It's like,
it feels sort of chefy and date 90,
but it's it,
it's the 30 minute meal.
Wow.
That's awesome.
Well listen man,
your books.
Awesome.
I've enjoyed a lot of your videos.
I've enjoyed you on television before as
a pleasure to have you on and get to
talk food and the origins and everything
with you.
And uh,
I heard,
I like are nonlinear conversation.
It's great.
It was fine.
That's all my goal.
That way I,
I urge people to go out if you're a,
if you're a hunter or if you're just a
fan of delicious food,
go out and check this out.
Buck Buck Moose by Hank shot and you
have other books available,
right with the other books.
My last one is duck duck goose,
which as you might guess is what bell or
found silly goose.
And then my first one is called Hunter
Gatherer Cook.
Okay.
And you are a hunt.
Gather Cook on twitter and same on
instagram.
Yep.
And do you have a facebook as well?
I do.
And it's a hunter angler.
Gardiner.
Okay.
Thank you brother.
This was really fun.
I really appreciate you coming on.
Absolutely.
Thanks everybody.
We'll be back tomorrow with James
Hetfield from metallica.